[Musique]
edouard si les doit s'exprimer dans une
trentaine de minutes en compagnie du
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand il
va dresser un bilan du confinement en
france il fera un point sur les
résultats de cette stratégie et les
attentes sont
istres devraient également évoquer les
premières pistes du déconfinement
progressif avec un début prévu le 11 mai
la pandémie de kobe de 19 qui frappe
durement l'europe cent mille morts soit
deux tiers des décès dans le monde le
vieux continent où le déconfinement
s'accélère après l'autriche le danemark
et l'italie et l'espagne cette semaine
c'est au tour de la république tchèque
et de la norvège de rouvrir certaines
écoles et crèches en allemagne et en
belgique quelques magasins sont de
nouveau ouverts foyer de la pandémie le
plus important dans le monde les etats
unis comptent désormais plus de 38000
mort et les mesures mises en place pour
lutter contre la propagation du colis 19
ne font pas l'unanimité
encouragé par donald trump des
manifestations anti confinement se sont
déroulées dans plusieurs villes
américaines
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france c'est
donc une prise de parole très attendue
dans environ 30 minutes le premier
ministre et le ministre de la santé vont
s'exprimer sur la situation en france
avec une date dans toutes les têtes
celle du 11 mai début du déconfinement
annoncé est cette conférence de presse
se veut comme un point d'étape sur la
pandémie alors que le bilan frôle les 20
mille morts 642 décès ont été
enregistrés ces dernières 24 heures à
menad positive pour le quatrième jour
consécutif le nombre de personnes
hospitalisées à baisser et celui des
patients en réanimation est également en
recul depuis dix jours autre signe
d'espoir la bulle ou une partie de
l'hôpital militaire de campagne commence
à être un démenti je vous le disais donc
le premier ministre edouard philippe
doit se prononcer dans maintenant une
demi heure à les attentes sont
nombreuses pour les français on va tout
de suite retrouvé en direct de matignon
notre reporter nadège abderrazak à
nadège bonjour alors la question du
déconfinement progressive dès le 11 mai
suscite depuis son annonce des
interrogations oui alors écoutez olivier
aujourd'hui cette conférence de presse
un d'edouard philippe et d'olivier
ferrand le ministre de la santé va avoir
pour but de faire un état des lieux de
la gestion liés aux coronavirus et puis
à de présenter les résultats du
confinement mis en place depuis le 17
mars edouard philippe devrait revenir
sur les choix de son gouvernement
expliquer comment et bien se fera après
confinement six jours après la dernière
allocution du président de la république
edouard philippe devrait aussi parler de
ce que l'on sait et ce que l'on ne sait
pas au sujet de cette épidémie on confie
son entourage le premier ministre elle
doit également évoquer à les premières
pistes d'un déconfinement qui s'annonce
je le disais compliqué à trois semaines
maintenant de l'échéance que se
passera-t-il après le 11 mai devra t'on
tous porter des masques pourra-t-on tous
se faire dépister des questions à qui
reste en suspens à trois semaines
maintenant de l'échéance
mir version du plan de sortie de crise
devrait être présenté ce mercredi en
conseil des ministres d'ici là le duo
edouard philippe olivier elles verront
continue de marteler que cette date du
11 mai n'est qu'une étape dans la
gestion de la crise lié aux kobe de 19
le coc vide elle 19 et bien qui a fait
jusqu'à aujourd'hui plus de 19 morts en
france merci beaucoup nadège pour toutes
ces précisions
en direct de matignon on le disait la
question du découvrons du déconfinement
progressive dès le 11 mai suscite depuis
son annonce des interrogations une
perspective d'ailleurs très critiqué cet
après midi par le député la france
insoumise des bouches-du-rhône jean-luc
mélenchon l'écoutent je trouve
hasardeuses à date du 11 mai pourquoi
pas le neuf le 12 ou le 4 comme nos amis
allemands
ce qui est important c'est la
planification l'organisation un
déconfinement non organisés est
dangereux car il y aura un deuxième pic
au déconfinement ramener les gosses à
l'école si on n'a pas pris des autres
mesures sanitaires nécessaires je pèse
mes mots
ça me met mal à l'aise alors la crise
sanitaire affecte le moral des français
mais aussi leur confiance dans
l'exécutif c'est ce qui ressort en tout
cas d'un sondage paru dans le monde
32% des personnes interrogées évoquent
ainsi un sentiment de méfiance 28% de la
morosité et à 27% de la peur des
chiffres en hausse depuis le mois de
février lors de sa dernière allocution
emmanuel macron s'était pourtant montré
rassurant cofondateur du monde moderne
alexina note une déconnexion du chef de
l'état entre ses paroles et ses actes
écouter la parole politique est
totalement déconsidéré parce qu'il y
avait trop de mensonges et que
effectivement on peut entendre un
discours c'est toujours bien mais ce qui
compte c'est les actes et en particulier
avec neil macron souvent les discours
sont loin voire à l'opposé des actes
cette façon de gouverner qui devrait
inquiéter tout le monde dans la solitude
dans l' isolement il n'a prévenu que
très peu de gens autour de son entourage
le premier ministre olivier ferrand à
propos de la date du 11 mai on ne sait
pas d'où elle sort d'où elle vient
alors il ya peut-être le conseil
scientifique qui est là pour l'aider à
prendre des décisions mais c'est un
grand pays la france ça ne peut pas être
géré depuis
le bureau d'un seul homme à l'elysée un
dès qu'on filme en tout cas qui inquiète
les agents du service central du
renseignement territoriale craignent des
violences sociales à la sortie et du
confinement et la situation est déjà
tendue la nuit dernière des heurts ont
éclaté à villeneuve la garenne dans les
hauts de seine après un accident de moto
impliquant des forces de l'ordre selon
une source policière
le conducteur de la moto roulait à vive
allure quand un fonctionnaire à bord
d'une voiture banalisée a ouvert la
porte de son véhicule et l'a percuté le
motard souffre d'une fracture ouverte à
la jambe une tension dans les banlieues
logique selon farid et aime sa manie le
porte parole de l'association banlieues
plus le confinement est vécue
difficilement danser dans ces
territoires il faut le dire très
clairement pas tous forcément respecter
un peu à l'échelle du pays mais mais un
peu plus dans ces quartiers là parce que
les logements sont parfois très
difficile à vivre lorsqu'on est nombreux
les équipements numériques ne sont pas
forcément accessibles et donc du coup
tout ceci entraîne un confinement pas
toujours respectée et qui entraîne une
tension supplémentaire là l'économie
étant complètement arrêté n'ayant pas de
solution de repli
parfois pas forcément de chômage partiel
comme d'autres peuvent la voir ou de
télétravail
effectivement ça devient très très très
tendue je rappelle vraiment et je salue
notamment les initiatives des
associations qui prennent le relais il
ya les gens qui à l'heure où je pars
n'ont pas de quoi manger dans leur
propre famille dans ces quartiers là la
situation est une véritablement assez
complexe et tendue avant la vie à toutes
les cérémonies commémoratives et
patriotes et patriotiques sont annulés
jusqu'au 11 y compris le mi mai
anniversaire de la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale de quoi enflammer les
réseaux sociaux philippe gosselin s'est
insurgé hier dans un courrier adressé à
emmanuel macron le député l ère de la
manche s'est dit scandalisé par
l'annulation de ces cérémonies
cette année marque le 75e anniversaire
la victoire sur le nazisme dans la
foulée de cette missive une partie de la
classe politique saisi l'occasion de
pointer les choix du gouvernement sur la
toile en particulier la secrétaire
d'état auprès de la ministre des armées
geneviève darrieussecq recadre voyez
plutôt
outré par l'adulation des cérémonies du
8 mai je demande à emmanuel macron de
revoir sa décision dans un format bien
sûr adapté
nous devons honorer nos glorieux morts
pour la france et la victoire contre le
totalitarisme
monsieur le président de la république
les français doivent pouvoir honorer
leurs glorieux morts pour la patrie 2020
75e anniversaire de la victoire sur le
nazisme à libération des camps retour
des prisonniers
la république est debout les cérémonies
du 8 mai sont annulés mais le onze tout
le monde pourra prendre les transports
en commun pour aller travailler et
envoyer ses enfants à l'école
soyez fiers d'être des amateurs quelle
indignité pour nos morts tombés pour la
france d'annuler les cérémonies locales
du 8 mai devant le monument aux morts le
maire peut tout à fait célébrer
prudemment avec un représentant des
anciens combattants en direct sur les
réseaux sociaux
c'est le minimum l'annulation des
cérémonies du 8 mai est une honte pour
les millions de morts de la seconde
guerre mondiale est un camouflet pour
tous les républicains
la république n'abdique jamais et ne se
confine pas un peu d'honneur de courage
et de respect non nous n'annulons pas le
8 mai pas de polémiques inutiles
il y aura une cérémonie nationale à
cette date le format sera seulement
adapté aux circonstances ce que chacun
peut comprendre en faisant preuve de bon
sens et lien t-il une négligence à bord
du porte avions charles de gaulle ou
1000 46 marins ont été contaminées par
le comique 19 pas de transgression mais
des mesures insuffisantes reconnaît
l'armée invité hier au 20 heures de tf1
le chef d'état major des armées a admis
que la lumière doit être encore être
faite sur les conditions dans lesquelles
60 pour son équipage avaient été
contaminés par le coronavirus pour
françois lecointre les procédures ont
été respectées à mais sans doute avec le
recul n'est elle n'était pas suffisante
écouter on a une enquête de commandement
qui permettra de préciser l'effet de
bien comprendre ce qui s'est passé et
d'en tirer des enseignements pour la
suite afin de savoir quel type 2
il faut que nous prenions sur des crises
équivalente ou sur nos autres bâtiments
il n'est pas question de juger
sanctionner ou stigmatiser les gens et
parmi les nombreuses activités fortement
perturbé en cette période celle des
avocats a déjà mises à mal par deux mois
de mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites il tourne toujours au ralenti
à grégoire doucet luis carballo ont
suivi une avocate à une regarde face aux
mesures de restriction les avocats
doivent s'adapter consultation par
téléphone des audiences qui se font
rares comme pour de nombreux secteurs
les robes noires font face à un
bouleversement de leur organisation et
une forte baisse d'activité le cas de
françoise royannaise ne déroge pas à la
règle
moi actuellement à lyon je n'ai aucun
retour des audiences qui n'ont pas pu se
tenir c'est à dire que celui-ci dans
celle sur dix ans est absolument pas là
là j'ai vu qu'aujourd'hui donc tous les
bâtons nombreux mais des liens il faut
cliquer cliquer clics et sans arrêt pour
essayer de savoir mais tous les jours on
a des informations qui modifient celle
de la veille donc j'ignore comment
effectivement la machine va se remettre
en marche et manifestement la crise a
démontré que l'action judiciaire
si on loue le télétravail eh ben elle
n'est pas équipée en télétravail
françoise est pessimiste concernant
l'avenir elles redoutent notamment
d'importantes pertes financières
ça serait très difficile et ce ne sera
pas rattrapable 1 le temps qui est
passée confiné elle va pouvoir plaider
un parent très nouveau dossier en ce qui
me concerne je n'ai aucun nouveau client
les onze ans chez eux sont difficultés
aussi on va voir toutes les difficultés
donc la presse sera encore plus dur je
pense que le présent les aides qu'elles
devraient percevoir de l'état
permettront probablement de sauver les
meubles mais les charges à payer reste
un véritable fardeau pour le mois de
mars apparemment je suis éligible
d'après ce que m'a dit mon
expert-comptable puisqu'il a une partie
de mes comptes pour percevoir l'aide de
1500 euros l'aide elle est mieux que
rien elle est la prise de conscience de
ce qu'il faut aider mais il est évident
que dans un cabinet c'est une aide qui
est très inférieur à l'arrêt
des chars et là c'est qu'avant de se
payer il faut payer les charges
après la bataille interrompu contre la
réforme des retraites
le confinement sonne comme un nouveau
coup dur pour les avocats de france et
le déconfinement s'accompagnera d'une
reprise économique le groupe michelin a
lui déjà rouvert ses usines en france
depuis mardi les ouvriers des
manufactures de pneus repris le chemin
du travail une reprise progressive mais
qui fait bondir les syndicats reportage
à cholet de solenn gaudin et de morgane
france en distance masque lavage des
mains des gestes barrières impossible à
appliquer dans cette usine qui emploie
près de 1400 salariés selon les
syndicats
le problème c'est que dans le sinn les
gens travaillent en binôme
au moins un obus nantes sur les machines
il ya du bruit et des consignes qu'on
doit se donner
on doit commis contre nous et pour
communiquer soit on enlève les
productions auditive % en soit on a une
soir on va enlever une masse pour crier
plus fort du côté du syndicat sud pas
question de reprendre le travail sans
avoir testé les salariés ce qu'on
souhaite c'est que tous les salariés
soient testés ce qui permettrait de
pouvoir au moins savoir si les salariés
sont porteurs ou pas puisqu'on sait très
bien que ce virus est très contagieux
donc qui pourraient se transmettre à
tout lusine et finalement on se verrait
à un arrêt complet de lusine dans les
semaines qui viennent mais une reprise
nécessaire pour la direction de michelin
qui prévoit de fabriquer des masques et
des pièces pour des respirateurs
artificiels trois usines commence la
fabrication de masques deux catégories
une et vont bientôt produire une
nouvelle génération de masques ffp2 pour
en fabriquer quelques millions relancer
la production de pneumatiques est
indispensable pour les véhicules de
secours
les camions les engins de génie civil un
argument qui masque la réalité selon la
cgt il ya 150 salariés qui vont
fabriquer des masques et il y en a 300
qui vont fabriquer des pneus quand même
c'est donner des gages aux marchés
financiers pour dire michelin est là et
on va produire ce n'est pas nécessaire
la rentabilité économique il s'oppose à
l'urgence sanitaire et donc il n'y a pas
d'urgence dans l'usiné de cholet
vendredi
syndicats ont alerté l'inspection du
travail pour danger grave et imminent
en attendant sa décision 500 ouvriers
retourneront l usine ce lundi en europe
maintenant et en espagne plus
précisément le bilan quotidien de la
pandémie baisse à 410 morts l'espagne
l'un des pays les plus touchés par la
crise sanitaire
plus de 20000 morts au total le
confinement est prolongée jusqu'au 9 mai
comme l'annoncé le premier ministre
pedro sanchez hier soir avec au passage
une bonne nouvelle aux parents et aux
enfants partir du 24 avril à partir du
27 avril le gouvernement espagnol
prendra des mesures d'allègement pour
l'aider confinement si je puis dire de
nos plus jeunes enfants afin qu'ils
puissent sortir dans la rue et profiter
au moins aussi des améliorations
comptable que nous constatons dans
l'évolution de la pandémie mais les
caches
elle a beau l'opium de l'apa même
ailleurs en europe plusieurs pays
amorcent leur déconfinement dès demain
en république tchèque
enfant étudiant retrouveront le chemin
de l'école et de l'université en norvège
ce sont les crèches qui rouvrent leurs
portes
de son côté l'allemagne autorise les
magasins de petite surface à rouvrir est
des mesures similaires déjà prises en
début de semaine par l'autriche et
l'italie ou encore l'espagne l'union
européenne européenne qui aura besoin de
500 milliards d'euros supplémentaires
pour se remettre de la crise une somme
qui viendrait s'ajouter à un montant
équivalent convenu il ya dix jours après
des semaines de tractations
selon le président du mécanisme européen
de stabilité c'est le fonds d'urgence de
la zone euro à la manière la plus simple
de réunir ses 500 milliards et de
mobiliser la commission européenne et le
budget de l'ue à elle les dirigeants de
l'union
elles doivent se réunir par
visioconférence le 23 avril pour dany
l'angle économiste et maître de
conférences à l'université paris xiii il
faudrait il aurait fallu dès le début de
la crise soutenir financièrement le
système de santé écoutez nous on va les
mettre cet argent sur la table en partie
avant et en particulier pour soutenir le
système de santé qui est et qui quand
même délabrée dans un certain nombre de
pays mais pour les autres secteurs
servait à rien ça sert à rien d'injecter
des liquidités dans l'économie
quand un certain nombre de secteurs sont
à l'arrêt et à mon avis il va falloir
faire un effort durable parce que là il
faut assurer le redémarrage dans
certains ont deux secteurs
il faudra surtout songer à ce que la
reprise soit durable et une reprise
durable
ça passe avant tout par la prise au
sérieux de la transition écologique
si on se retrouve dans cette situation
sanitaire délabré et désastreux c'est
aussi à cause d'un vent de viabilisation
libéral est allé et aussi à cause du
délabrement du système de santé et du
système de santé dans qu'on a à travers
le mans donc il faut des sommes
conséquentes pour aller leur la
transition écologique il va falloir
investir massivement pour aller vers une
relocalisation des insultes des
industries donc tout ça demande des
milliards
et effectivement je ne suis pas certain
que 500 milliards suffiront et au
royaume uni l'épidémie continue de
progresser 596 morts supplémentaires à
l'hôpital ces dernières 24 heures plus
de 16 mille décès au total et au delà de
120 milles 4 contamination confirmés
avec une inquiétude importantes
notamment dans les maisons de retraite
où certains redoute un bilan dramatique
médias ce qui fit des centaines de décès
supplémentaires constatés toutes les 24
heures déjà très lourd le bilan humain
annoncé par les autorités britanniques
ne prend en compte que les décès à
l'hôpital sans comptabiliser ceux des
établissements pour personnes âgées
certains responsables du secteur déplore
cette situation nous avons plusieurs
résidants dans 10 de nos quinze maisons
de retraite qui ont des symptômes
ressemblant à des symptômes du kobe 19
le problème c'est que nous n'avons pas
accès à des dépistages pour eux
sont à peine à obtenir des dépistages
pour notre personnel soignant dans les
maisons de retraite mais c'est loin
d'être le cas pour les résidents selon
karine grind un organisme qui représente
les maisons de retraite indépendante
près de 7500 personnes seraient mortes
dans ces résidences pour seniors
bien loin des 217 dénombrés par le
bureau des statistiques nationales
à l'heure actuelle les maisons de
retraite sont en première ligne pendant
de nombreuses années notre secteur a été
négligée mais à présent nous sommes en
première ligne dans la lutte contre le
kobe 19 et nous avons besoin de plus de
soutien de la part du gouvernement
certaines personnes âgées parviennent
néanmoins combattre le kobe de 19 comme
cette patiente de 106 ans prise en
charge à birmingham après trois semaines
d'hospitalisation
vous vous souvenez ce matin nous
discutions et vous vous souvenez que je
vous ai dit que vous étiez la personne
la plus âgée à survivre à ce méchant
virus qui circule au oui selon public
allthings les autorités de santé locales
3084 maison de retraite en angleterre
compter des cas de coronavirus à la date
du 15 avril
interrogé sur cet épineux dossier le
ministre britannique de la santé matin
tu quoque reconnaît que le nombre réel
de morts est plus grand il assure qu'un
bilan officiel sera publié dans les
prochains jours
avec 38 1664 morts et plus de 730 semi
le contaminer les etats-unis sont le
pays le plus touché au monde par le
coronavirus pourtant les manifestations
anti confinement se multiplient sur le
territoire dans l'ohio en californie ou
encore au texas des rassemblements pour
un juif par les déclarations de donald
trump
le président américain a appelé à se
rebeller contre le confinement
il estime que certains gouverneurs sont
allés trop loin dans les mesures de
restriction j'ai remarqué qu'il y avait
eu beaucoup de manifestations et je
pense que certains gouverneurs sont
allés trop loin
vous savez il y a beaucoup de gens qui
n'ont pas besoin qu'on leur dise quoi
faire ils ont vraiment fait tout ce que
nous leur avons demandé il ya quelques
états ou franchement j'ai parlé au
gouverneur et j'aurais pu leur dire quoi
faire si je l'avais voulu cela aurait
peut-être été politiquement correct des
what will break et randall aux
présidents des républicains envers six
appels à écouter les citoyens écoutez
c'est aussi une question des libertés
d'expression et le droit de manifester
aux états unis qui est limitée qui est
bien entendu aujourd'hui on a une
difficulté à exprimer certaines
personnes dans certains états qui
s'estiment lésés par cette situation qui
n'ont plus rien pour vivre et qui
veulent aller au travail et peut-être il
ya des mesures qui peuvent être vus par
certains gouverneurs et qui est le
peuple à faire entendre sa position dont
ses cadres à des dissensions coexister
et commentant le peuple sans qu il ya
des manifestations permet de les faire
on est aujourd'hui confronté à une
situation où chaque gouvernement
présente sa position sont que le peuple
soit entendu sur leurs positions l'eau
possibilité de gagner leur vie et à
leurs factures c'est très difficile pour
beaucoup d'américains pour faire face à
leurs vies tous les jours et il faut les
entendre des manifestations anti
confinement au brésil également de
nombreux habitants de riz
sont descendus dans la rue pour
critiquer les mesures de restriction
prises par le gouvernement local
une réaction qui fait suite à la prise
de position de jaillir ball sonar au le
président brésilien qui a de nouveau
critiqué le confinement
cette manifestation automobile n'est pas
contre l'isolément mais contre le
confinement qui affectent l'économie
soit on a juste la pandémie ce qui est
déjà beaucoup
soit on à la pandémie et le chaos et
c'est ce vers quoi le pays va tourner la
vie est certainement la chose la plus
importante que toute autre chose
on ne peut pas prendre de décision
aujourd'hui sans penser à demain parce
que demain je ne sais pas dans quel état
sera le père de famille quand il verra
ses enfants affamés à l'iran annonce la
prolongation des permissions de sortie
pour certains détenus cent mille
prisonniers sont concernés par cette
mesure
il s'agit selon le président iranien de
limiter la propagation du cog hill 19
dans les prisons iraniennes écoutez moi
en permission de sortie devait être
accordées aux détenus jusqu'à la fin de
farzad in le 19 avril
mais maintenant avec les mêmes
conditions seuls les prisonniers dont la
liberté ne présente aucun danger peuvent
bénéficier d'une permission qui sera
prolongé jusqu'à la fin mai le pouvoir
judiciaire a pris des décisions
importantes à ce sujet et nous avons
également pris des décisions
ces décisions celle du pouvoir
judiciaire en plus d'autorité à cet
égard en israël sortie de crise
sanitaire progressive le pays sort peu à
peu du déconfinement mais au plan
politique
israël est toujours affecté par une
crise gouvernementale sans précédent
retour en images sur cette crise qui
dure depuis plus d'un an
[Musique]
[Rires]
tous
[Musique]
on
et pour animer sika analyste politique
ancien porte parole du likoud
un accord est proche d'être trouvé entre
benny gantz et benyamin netanyahou il en
est dans un pays qui est extrêmement
démocratique donc on est bien sûr dans
un dans un moment un peu critique bien
entendu puisque vous avez trois fois
qu'on représente que les u 10 pts se
présentent aux urnes mais je pense
qu'effectivement il ya une possibilité
pour une raison très simple c'est que on
peut pas aller vers une quatrième
élection c'est pas possible surtout dans
ce contexte sécuritaire plutôt son
contexte sanitaire qui fait que le pays
est vraiment dans dans la panade comme
tous beaucoup d'autres pays du monde
donc on ne peut pas donc il va forcément
y avoir on espère dans les quelques
heures qui viennent on va trouver un
accord et on va avoir un gouvernement
qui va être plutôt un gouvernement
d'union nationale comme on l'appelle ici
ici dans ce contexte il est plus que
jamais nécessaire de respecter les
gestes barrière à madagascar les plantes
médicinales endémique représente
également pour certains un rempart
contre la pandémie
une tisane préventive a été mise sur le
marché par l'institut malgache de
recherche appliquée le récit d'un abbé
licence
on ne trouve cet arbre qu'à madagascar
ravintsara signifie bonnes feuilles
cette espèce endémique et sans doute la
plus convoitée du pays désormais le
ravintsara on utilise habituellement
qu'on a de la fièvre et mal à la tête
on fait une inhalation on fait bouillir
les feuilles avec le loup dans la
marmite et on en boit aussi pour y
donner l'eau avec les mort dit les loups
c'est en gros le rabin sarr utilisé en
décoction depuis des générations par les
malgaches est également au centre des
attentions scientifique pour ses vertus
anti viral expectorantes les bonnes
feuilles font partie du cocktail de
plantes mises au point par l'institut
malgache de recherche appliquée dans le
cadre de la prévention du coc vide 19
dans la hotte de cette commerciale
distributrice pour livrer les premiers
exemplaires à destination de la
population de nocibé je fais du
porte-à-porte pour approvisionner le
plus de monde possible dans ce sachet le
rabin sarre dans tous ses états en
huiles essentielles et en tisane mélangé
à d'autres plantes médicinales cette
idée je vais faire les c'est parce que
le président a dit que ces herbes
pouvait constituer des barrières contre
le coronavirus même si on n'est pas
encore touchée par la maladie praticiens
le faire prévention ne vous prévenir que
guérir
adam sources fiables
depuis l'annoncé des premiers cas de
kobe de 19 dans la grande île le 20 mars
dernier
quarante mille kits de prévention
familial comme celui là ont été vendues
avec l'aval du président de la
république lui-même après avoir vanté la
solution préventive par les plantes
andrade joël rey affirme le 8 avril
l'existence d'un remède en phase d'essai
clinique un remède à base de plantes
endémiques à la composition bien gardé
censée changer le cours de l'histoire
il ya le savoir faire ancestral et il ya
les vérifications en laboratoire et
ça fait plus de dix ans que je me
retrouve dans la peau ma thérapie et
l'état étudié les plantes à madagascar
donc j'ai beaucoup d'espoir ça génère
désespoir la mention
à propos du fait qu'on a trouvé un
remède à couronne hariri de l'espoir et
des ventes dans ce magasin spécialisé en
aromathérapie les stock d'huile
essentielle de ravintsara s'écoule deux
fois plus vite que le mois dernier cette
française résidente à nocibé fait partie
des convaincus sa liste en main
elisabeth projet fait le plein leur
habitat l'union lit et le shar haut et
très fort qui verra et que les huiles
essentielles alors avec ça ça est
ridicule
madagascar knicks le succès du rabin
sarr dépasse les frontières de
madagascar la demande est forte mais le
président de madagascar à mon avis hein
juste tic pour éviter soit de la
spéculation sur les matières premières
soit une utilisation incomplètes ou
nocives de certains produits a bloqué
l'exportation de toutes les plantes
endémiques à madagascar
l'occasion faisant le larron il ya
beaucoup de produits qui ne sont ni
analysés ni contrôlées en termes de
qualité en terme de pouvoir médicaux qui
sont mis sur le marché pour son informel
de plus en plus de produits non
homologués en circulation avec des prix
qui s'envolent depuis le début de la
crise la valeur des fameuses bonnes
feuilles aurait été multiplié par cinq
et partout dans le monde les
laboratoires travaillent d'arrache-pied
à la mise au point d'un traitement
efficace contre le coronavirus aucun
remède miracle pour l'instant mais
certaines pistes semblent prometteuses
et illustrations au japon un médicament
focalise l'attention des chercheurs il
s'agit de la vie grand à des tests sont
en cours pour déterminer l'efficacité du
produit contre le colis de 19 à quelques
explications en images
[Musique]
[Rires]
une semaine après les catholiques et les
protestants c'est au tour des chrétiens
orthodoxes de fêter pâques
ce dimanche les orthodoxes suivent en
effet le calendrier julien quand les
autres confessions chrétiennes suivent
le calendrier grégorien et cette année
une paille cents fidèles les autorités
les ont invités à rester chez eux pour
limiter la propagation du coronavirus
c'est le cas en russie chez à la demande
du patriarche de moscou
les cérémonies pascales se sont tenues
le plus souvent à huis clos dans des
églises vides
draghi losilla chers amis je souhaite à
tous les chrétiens orthodoxes de bonne
fête en ce jour de la sainte
résurrection du christ pour la grande
fête de la sant pack se mettait presque
cette année le festival de la pâque
orthodoxe se déroule avec des
restrictions qui nous sont imposés elles
sont nécessaires pour lutter contre la
propagation de la maladie
déjà connue dans le monde entier nous
analysons attentivement les expériences
dans d'autres pays nous interagissons
activement avec nos amis et collègues
étrangers
we knew même ville
nous comprenons ce qui se passe nous
voyons les risques nous savons ce qui
doit être fait dans tous les scénarios
et nous faisons ce qui est nécessaire à
tous les niveaux du gouvernement
travaille régulièrement de manière
ordonnée et responsable la situation est
sous contrôle total
toute notre société est unie face à
cette menace commune et en egypte comme
ailleurs dans le monde
une pâques orthodoxe que tentent dé
fêter les fidèles aujourd'hui tour du
monde en images
[Musique]
les temps
roxane
[Musique]
paullo
oh
il faut lui
la priorité au direct sur rt france avec
la conférence de presse du premier
ministre edouard philippe on écoute avec
le ministre des solidarités de la santé
olivier vers ans j'avais tenu à
organiser une conférence de presse ici
dans les bureaux du premier ministre à
matignon pour expliquer le plus
complètement possible le plus clairement
possible
quel était notre stratégie face à
l'épidémie de covile 19 pour vous dire
ce que nous savions et ce que nous ne
savions pas pour vous dire ce que nous
faisions ce que nous espérions et ce que
nous redoutions comme je m'y étais
engagé alors j'ai décidé de revenir
devant vous aujourd'hui pour poursuivre
cet exercice de clarté de transparence
d'explications sur ce que nous vivons
car nous vivons chacun l'a bien compris
une crise sans précédent
une crise sanitaire d'abord d'une très
grande intensité
ça n'est évidemment pas la première
épidémie qui sévit en france ce n'est
pas non plus la plus meurtrière des
épidémies qu'a connu la france dans son
histoire
mais cette épidémie parce qu'elle est
meurtrière pour les plus fragiles
d'entre nous parce qu elles provoquent
très grand nombre de cas sévères qui
impose des admissions dans les services
de réanimation ou de soins intensifs et
qui se faisant sous mais notre système
de soins à une pression considérable est
d'une ampleur que nous n'avons pas connu
dans l'histoire moderne
cette crise sanitaire et je voudrais
insister là dessus parce que pour
beaucoup de gens c'est l'évidence mais
qu'il faut parfois redire les évidences
cette crise sanitaire
elle n'est pas terminée bien sûr nous
marquons des points contre l'épidémie
bien sûr et heureusement la situation
s'améliore progressivement
lentement mais sûrement le président de
la république l'a dit l'espoir renaît
mais nous ne sommes pas sortis de la
crise sanitaire
imaginez que parce que là si la
situation aurait cessé de s'aggraver et
qu'elle commencerait à s'améliorer
l'épidémie serait derrière nous ça ce
serait une erreur
cette crise sanitaire soumet encore nos
soignants et tous ceux qui les
accompagnent qui leur permettent de
faire leur travail à une pression
considérable
cette crise sanitaire fait encore des
morts chaque jour nos compatriotes
perdent des parents
conjointe des amis des gens qui ont
compté dans leur vie ils les pleurs et
ils ne peuvent pas les accompagner comme
il l'aimerait ils ne peuvent pas leur
rendre hommage comme il le souhaiterait
tous ceux qui ont perdu des proches
savent le poids de ces moments et je
veux très simplement et très simplement
leur dire que nous pensons comme je
pense aux 30000 français hospitalisé
aujourd'hui qui lutte contre cette
maladie
aidés par des femmes et des hommes
compétents et dévoués que je remercie
une fois encore cette crise sanitaire
qui n'est pas terminée va entraîner une
crise économique
cette crise là la crise économique ne
fait que commencer
elle sera brutal au moment où je vous
parle
une bonne moitié de l'humanité demeure
confiner la production en france et dans
une très grande partie du monde s'est
presque arrêtée la consommation aussi
jamais dans l'histoire du monde un tel
arrêt aussi massif aussi général aussi
brutale n'a été vécue jamais pour
accompagner et soutenir celles et ceux
qui subissent cette situation pour
préserver notre capacité de rebond aussi
nous avons pris des mesures et nous
continuerons à en prendre
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir enfin
nous devons organiser notre vie pour les
mois qui viennent
alors je sais qu évidemment beaucoup
d'entre vous s'interrogent sur ce qui va
se passer au moment du décompte final
sur la façon dont la vie va reprendre
une fois le confinement levées sur la
façon dont nous allons pouvoir
recommencer à travailler à nous déplacer
à voyager à étudier à faire du sport à
retrouver nos amis nos proches bref sur
la façon dont nous allons pouvoir
recommencer à vivre librement ces
questions elles sont légitimes
je sais que beaucoup de ceux qui nous
regardent
aimerait que j'entre dans le détail de
ce qui va se passer le 11 mai et dans
les jours les semaines et les mois qui
suivront je ne répondrai pas à toutes
ces questions aujourd'hui je le ferai
bientôt dans les quinze jours qui
viennent lorsque je présenterai le plan
que le président de la république m'a
demandé de préparer
il est en train d'être travaillé dans
tous ses détails et nous serons au
rendez vous ce que je veux présenter
aujourd'hui ce sont les principes que
nous avons retenu pour élaborer ce plan
les grandes règles qui vont devoir
s'appliquer en ayant toujours à l'idée
mesdames et messieurs que notre vie à
partir du 11 mai ce ne sera pas
exactement la vie d'avant le confinement
pas tout de suite et probablement pas
avant longtemps mais comme nous avons
réussi le confinement ensemble nous
allons réussir ensemble le déconfinement
comme nous avons appris à nous battre
contre le virus
nous allons apprendre progressivement à
organiser notre vie collective avec ce
virus en mettant en oeuvre de nouvelles
habitudes en vivant dans un quotidien
qui sera un peu différent mais en
retrouvant la liberté à laquelle nous
sommes attachés
ce sera notre prochain défi et nous nous
allons y arriver avec olivier ferrand le
ministre des solidarités de la santé
avec la professeur florence adhère nous
allons vous présenter le poids précis de
la situation aujourd'hui dimanche 19
avril vous montrer les résultats que
nous avons obtenus vous indiquer où sont
nos incertitudes les risques auxquels
nous devons faire face
ce que nous ne savons pas et que nous
devons pourtant tenté d'anticiper pour
prendre les bonnes décisions
et puis nous vous indiquerons comment
nous allons préparer
comment nous préparons déjà le plan qui
va organiser le déconfinement progressif
qui commencera le 11 mai mais avant tout
cela
je vais demander aux professeurs salomon
le directeur général de la santé ne vous
présentez comme nous en avons pris
l'habitude la situation sanitaire au 19
avril
monsieur le directeur général de la
santé ce premier ministre messieurs
ministre mesdames et messieurs nous
observons aujourd'hui encore une lente
décrue très lente décrue épidémique mais
le nombre de personnes hospitalisées
reste très élevé il est aujourd'hui de
30 mille six cent dix malades
hospitalisés c'est encore 890 nouveaux
patients qui ont été admis au cours des
dernières 24 heures fort heureusement le
solde est négatif
29 malades hospitalisées en moins mais
vous le nôtre et c'est une très légère
baisse
en tout 80 mille personnes ont été
hospitalisées depuis le début de cette
épidémie
mais heureusement le confinement grâce à
vos efforts à tous est efficace il
freine fortement l'épidémie 5744 malade
dans un état grave sont encore en
réanimation
ce sont 137 nouveaux malades qui ont été
admis au cours des dernières 24 heures
forte heureusement le solde est négatif
depuis 11 jours
89 malades en moins c'est important pour
les malades mais c'est aussi très
important pour l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé
trente six mille cinq cent
soixante-dix-huit personnes sont déjà
rentrés à d'homicide sortie de l'hôpital
auxquels il faut ajouter toutes les
personnes qui sont guéris à la maison
sans passer par l'hôpital
l'activité en ville diminue
progressivement 1286 passages aux
urgences pour suspicion de kobe 19 470
cette intervention de sos médecins
vous le savez nous sommes très attentifs
à la situation au sein des
établissements sociaux et médico-sociaux
5725 établissements signal décade de
coronavirus soixante trois mille trois
cent trente six cas confirmés ou
possible et nous surveillons aussi bien
entendu la mortalité liée à cette
pandémie 12069 décès survenu en milieu
hospitalier depuis le 1er mars 7649 au
sein des établissements sociaux et
médico sociaux
nous déplorons ce soir 19 1718 décès
imputés à la maladie qu'ovide 19 au
cours de ses sept dernières semaines
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
directeur général de la santé au delà de
la cie de la présentation des résultats
des dernières 24 heures je voudrais
revenir sur les résultats que nous
sommes en train d'obtenir en le faisant
avec là aussi beaucoup de sérieux
beaucoup de précision beaucoup
d'humilité bien entendu et en indiquant
à chacun la nécessité de ne pas relâcher
nos efforts je vais vous en expliquer
les raisons
je voudrais commencer par rappeler en un
mot parce que je crois que beaucoup
d'entre nous maîtrise bien désormais
cette stratégie est rappelé qu elle a
été notre stratégie est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons décidé du
confinement dans lequel nous sommes
aujourd'hui place et nous avons en temps
normal en france 5000 lits de
réanimation environ 5000 lits de
réanimation et nous savons c'est la
courbe rouge que vous voyez sur votre
écran nous savons que si l'épidémie
progresse normalement
compte tenu de la très grande proportion
de cas sévères qu'elles suscitent
le nombre de cas sévères qui
justifierait d admission en réanimation
va augmenter avec le temps et devenir si
important qu'il va dépasser les
capacités d'admission en service de
réanimation
et là évidemment on a un très gros
problème parce que si on est au delà de
notre capacité d'admission en lits de
réanimation ça veut dire que tout ce qui
devrait aller en réanimation vont voir
leurs chances de soins et de survie
réduite à néant
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
développé une stratégie autour de deux
axes d'abord augmenter nos capacités
d'accueil dans les services de
réanimation c'est la ligne en pointillés
verts que vous voyez sur votre écran
c'est à dire faire en sorte que nous
puissions accueillir plus de malades et
c'est dans le même temps confinés la
population pour faire en sorte que la
circulation du virus ralentissent
et qu'en conséquence le nombre de cas
sévères soit moins important est que
nous soyons toujours en mesure d'avoir
un nombre de cas sévères qui justifie
les admissions en service de réanimation
inférieur à la capacité d'accueil dans
ses services
c'est la raison du confinement et c'est
ce que vous avez fait en respectant le
confinement est ce que les services
hospitaliers ont fait en augmentant leur
capacité d'accueil cette décision de
procéder au confinement pour produire
ses effets il fallait que l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens la respecte et la mettre
en oeuvre et nous avons pu constater que
les français dans leur immense majorité
nos concitoyens ont respecté les
consignes qui leur était donné les
chiffres que nous observons sont
éloquents en la matière une diminution
drastique du nombre de déplacements vers
les commerces vers les épiceries vers
les stations de transport garou pour les
endroits où on peut aller chercher les
transports publics vers les bureaux vous
avez constaté comme moi partout en
france dans les villes dans les villages
une immense diminution du nombre de
déplacements et un respect du
confinement qui a été globalement très
satisfaisant pour vérifier qu'ils
étaient bien respectées nous avons
évidemment mis en place des contrôles la
police la gendarmerie les polices
municipales ont été amenées à exercer un
très grand nombre de contrôles de
l'ordre de 13 millions et demi c'est
plus de 800 mille infractions ont été
constatées
ce respect du confinement il a produit
ses effets puisque je vous disais que
nous avions réussi à augmenter notre
capacité d'accueil dans les services de
réanimation de 5000 en temps normal à
10500 un mot quand même pour que vous
puissiez juger de l'exploit de notre
système hospitalier qu'en temps normal
je voulais dit nous avons cinq mille
lits de réanimation de réanimation mais
ils sont occupés
le taux d'occupation normal de ces lits
de réanimation est de l'ordre de 85 à
90% ça veut dire que hors épidémie à
n'importe quel moment il y a de l'ordre
de 4000 à 4500 lits de réanimation qui
sont occupés et donc à n'importe quel
moment un volant de 500 lits de
réanimation disponible est libre avec
l'apparition du coronavirus avec
l'apparition de la maladie
covin 19 fons attendait et on redoutait
et on a constaté une explosion du nombre
de malades devant être admis en
réanimation il angoisse
c'était donc que aux malades j'allais
dire des temps normaux s'additionnent
près de dix mille voire plus malade
devant être admis en réanimation à
raison du coc vie de 19 ce qui aurait
littéralement saturé notre capacité
d'accueil le confinement et son respect
a permis d'obtenir les chiffres que vous
voyez sur la courbe qui s'affichent au
pic au moment où nous avons eu dans les
hôpitaux français le plus grand nombre
de malades qu'ovide 19
nous avons atteint le chiffre de 7100 ce
chiffre a diminué
le directeur général de la santé vient
de l'évoquer il est aujourd'hui de
l'ordre de 5800 un peu mois encore après
les chiffres d'aujourd'hui
ce qui veut dire qu après avoir atteint
ce qu'on a appelé le pic
nous descendons progressivement jour
après jour nous diminuons le nombre de
malades hospitalisés et le nombre de
add hospitalisées dans des services de
réanimation la diminution est lente
elle est progressive elle est certaine
au sens où comme elle traduit les effets
de la très grande
du très grand ralentissement de la
circulation du virus elle devrait se
poursuivre si et seulement si si et
seulement si le confinement est
respectée dans les semaines qui viennent
cette diminution du nombre de patients
que vides 19 est évidemment une bonne
nouvelle mais elle doit être appréciée
avec retenue et avec prudence car 5800
patients exclusivement malades du cobp
id dans les services de réanimation
c'est absolument considérable c'est plus
que l'ensemble de la capacité d'accueil
en temps normal c'est un effort pour les
services soignants absolument
considérable et nous avons donc besoin
dans les semaines qui viennent de
poursuivre la diminution de cette
occupation des lits de réanimation de
reconstituer nos forces de faire se
reposer
les équipes de soignants qui dans
certaines régions ont été soumises à une
pression un stress absolument
considérable à cause de la suractivité
il faut qu'elle puisse refaire leurs
forces le confinement a fonctionné et je
voudrais pour que nous puissions nous en
convaincre
vous montrez des cartes que j'avais
présenté il y a trois semaines lors de
la conférence de presse que nous avions
tenu avec olivier ferrand nous avions
indiqué que sans le confinement
il était acquis que l'épidémie allait se
propager partout en france et que nous
allions saturé partout en france
nos services de réanimation et je vous
avais présenté ce qui était notre
objectif c'est à dire les trois cartes
qui se trouve en bas de votre écran un
confinement qui permet de limiter la
circulation du virus est de faire en
sorte que
seules quelques régions voient leurs
capacités d'accueil saturées et que nous
puissions les soulager avec les
capacités d'accueil dans les autres
régions c'est ce qui s'est passé et si
on présente la situation aujourd'hui en
terme d'occupation des lits de
réanimation
nous avons cette carte qui montre que la
stratégie de confinement et donc de
limitation de la circulation de virus a
correctement fonctionné
ce dont nous devons nous réjouir et ceux
qui vous montre à la fois le très grand
civisme des français et la remarquable
capacité de nos concitoyens à s'adapter
à une situation jamais vue c'est assez
la carte de la france métropolitaine
mais il ne faut pas oublier les
territoires ultramarins
il ne faut pas les oublier parce que les
nous avons souvent l'occasion de le dire
présente des caractéristiques qui font
que leur situation sanitaire est souvent
plus fragile que celle qui prévaut dans
l'hexagone c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons pris des mesures s'agissant
des outre-mer très tôt par rapport à la
vitesse de circulation du virus par
rapport à l'arrivée de l'épidémie
la stratégie qui a été mise en oeuvre
dans les outre-mer est la même que celle
qui a été mise en oeuvre partout sur le
territoire
limitation de la circulation du virus
grâce au confinement augmentation des
capacités d'accueil dans les hôpitaux
grâce à l'extension du nombre
l'accroissement du nombre de lits de
réanimation mais en plus en outre mer
nous avons pris des mesures plus fortes
avec des couvre feux qui ont été
imposées avec des systèmes de 14 n part
de quarantaine qui ont été imposées pour
toute personne arrivant sur les îles où
sur le territoire
bref nous avons lu nous avons voulu
faire en sorte de préserver au maximum
les territoires et les départements
d'outre-mer de l'arrivée et du
développement du virus
au total nous pouvons dire aujourd'hui
avec beaucoup de prudence que cette
stratégie est pour l'instant payante
nous étions à 100 71 lits de réanimation
sur l'ensemble des territoires
d'outre-mer avant la crise nous sommes
montés aujourd'hui à 310 lits
l'augmentation est considérable et la
circulation du virus est faible contenu
ce qui nous laisse à penser et je le dis
avec beaucoup de prudence et sans que
cela ne doivent se traduire par un
relâchement des efforts au contraire
mais l'évolution de l'épidémie semble
compte tenu des mesures qui ont été
prises et du bon respect de ces mesures
sous contrôle le système a tenu le
système hospitalier est tenu au prix
d'efforts considérables c'est vrai et
grâce à une solidarité nationale et
européenne qu'il faut souligner pour
soulager les hôpitaux des régions dans
lesquelles le plus grand nombre de
malades étaient constatés la région
grand est
la région ile-de-france les hauts de
france la bourgogne et la franche-comté
ainsi que la corse
nous avons mis en place des opérations
d'évacuation sanitaire vers les hôpitaux
se situant dans des territoires où
l'épidémie était beaucoup moins forte
la circulation du virus beaucoup plus
faible et les capacités d'accueil bien
plus grand
les 644 transfert qui ont été effectués
dans cette période très brève constitue
je le dis à la fois pour en féliciter
les promoteurs et pour dire à nos
compatriotes combien ils peuvent être
fiers de ces opérations
c'est 644 transfert ou constitué un
exploit logistique remarquable un
exploit médical remarquable et un
exploit humain qu'il faut souligner
ils ont permis de sauver des vies ils
ont permis de montrer l'incroyable
solidarité entre régions des systèmes
hospitaliers et ils ont été réalisées en
france dans des conditions qui sont
probablement unique qui n'ont d'ailleurs
pas été reproduite dans beaucoup des
pays qui confrontés à des difficultés
telles que celles que nous connaissons
aurait probablement aimé pouvoir
procéder à ce type d'opération sur ces
six cent quarante quatre transferts un
nombre non négligeable
plus de 180 l'ont été vers des pays amis
et frontaliers l'allemagne la suisse le
luxembourg l'autriche qui - frontalière
qui dans moi un pays ami et je veux très
sincèrement remercier l'ensemble des
autorités politiques et sanitaires qui
ont permis ces transferts et qui nous
ont apporté leur concours à un moment de
grande difficulté
la question des masques a été beaucoup
discuté et je veux y revenir pour
indiquer où nous en sommes
depuis le début de la crise notre
objectif a été de faire en sorte que les
soignants les personnels hospitaliers et
tous ceux qui contribuent au
fonctionnement de l'hôpital puisse être
munis des masques ffp2 ou chirurgicaux
dont ils ont besoin pour exercer leurs
missions au mois de janvier lorsque la
crise a commencé à être évoquée nous
disposions j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
plusieurs fois d'un stock de 117
millions de masques chirurgicaux 117
millions de masques chirurgicaux
ce stock de 117 millions de masques
chirurgicaux
il doit être rapprochée de la
consommation hebdomadaire des
établissements hospitaliers français en
temps normal qui est de l'ordre de 5
millions autrement dit au mois de
janvier nous avions un stock de 23 à 24
semaines d' avance sur la consommation
normale des masques en milieu
hospitalier et nous avions au mois de
janvier une production nationale de
masques normal de 4 millions de masques
5 millions de consommation hebdomadaire
4 millions de production et un stock 217
ce qui est apparu au cours du mois de
février et du début du mois de mars
c'est plusieurs choses d'abord le fait
que les sources d'approvisionnement que
nous avions l'habitude d'utiliser pour
importer des masques se sont taries mais
elles se sont taries parce que la chine
notamment
confrontées à l'épidémie a concentré son
utilisation de masques sur son
territoire qu'elle a cessé une partie de
son activité en prenant des décisions de
confinement et qu'il a donc été très
difficile pour nous et pour tous les
autres en vérité
d'aller chercher des masques de
commander et de faire venir ses basques
dans une période où le système de
production chinois était ralenti et où
la consommation chinoise augmentait
considérablement
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
décidé d'augmenter la production
nationale 2 4 millions que j'ai évoquées
par semaine au mois de janvier
nous sommes aujourd'hui à plus de 8
millions nous avons déjà doublé la
capacité de madère nationale et nous
allons continuer à augmenter la capacité
de production nationale de façon à là
encore permettre à notre industrie et à
nos hôpitaux d'être à la hauteur du défi
de la consommation hospitalière et
depuis le mois de mars les importations
en provenance de chine ont pu reprendre
elles ont reprises parce que le système
a recommencé à fonctionner et nous avons
pu ramener des masques grâce à un pont
aérien mis en place par la france qui a
permis de faire en sorte d'augmenter
considérablement semaine après semaine
le nombre de masques importés dans notre
pays vous voyez sur le document qui est
vous est présentée que cette semaine
pour la première fois depuis longtemps
nous avons réussi à importer beaucoup
plus de masques que ce que nous
consommons en ce moment 81 millions hors
un peu moins de 80 millions de masques à
porter pour une consommation
hebdomadaire de l'ordre de 45 millions
ces bons chiffres nous permettre et le
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
aura l'occasion d'y revenir nous
permettent d'envisager un élargissement
de la politique de distribution des
masques dans les prochaines semaines
dernier point sur lequel je veux
insister s'agissant de ce qui a été fait
et de ce que vous devez donc savoir le
rapatriement des français au moment du
confinement un très grand nombre de nos
concitoyens se trouvaient à l'étranger
soit parce que pour des raisons précises
et professionnelle ils devaient voyager
soit parce qu'ils étaient en vacances
soit parce qu' il allait rejoindre un
ami un conjoint bref pour mille raisons
toutes valables
il se trouvait hors des frontières
nationales il a fallu qu'il revienne et
vous savez que très rapidement et
parfois très brutalement les autorités
nationales des différents états ont pris
la décision de fermer les frontières de
fermer les aéroports que le nombre de
vols s'est considérablement réduit et
qu'il était donc difficile pour tous les
français les 160000 français qui se
trouvaient en dehors des frontières de
façon passagère et qui avait vocation à
revenir rapidement sur le territoire
national il se trouvait très difficile
de rentrer ils étaient dispersés dans
plus de 100 pays
le ministère de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères a mis en oeuvre à travers sa
cellule de crise à travers ces postes
diplomatiques dans des conditions
parfois à simples et parfois
redoutablement compliqué une très grande
opération de d'organisation et de
facilitation du retour des nationaux
vers la france près de 1600 vols ont été
affrétés de façon à permettre à nos
concitoyens de revenir
et là encore je veux le dire à nos
compatriotes ce que la france a réalisé
a été rarement réalisées par les pays
comparables
nous avons eu la capacité collectivement
parfois c'était difficile parfois
c'était un petit peu plus long que ce
que chacun aurait aimé mais nous avons
eu collectivement la capacité de faire
rentrer 160000 français dans des
conditions je le rappelle parfois bien
délicate et je veux remercier les postes
diplomatiques et l'ensemble de ceux qui
ont contribué à cet effort national
voilà ce que je voulais dire s'agissant
des résultats tels que nous pouvons les
qualifiés à ce stade je voudrais
maintenant passer la parole à olivier
ferrand le ministre des solidarités de
la santé pour qu'ils nous pour qu'il
nous parle des défis des prochains jours
et des prochaines semaines le ministre
c'est à vous monsieur le premier
ministre un les défis que nous avons
relevé les défis que nous relevons et
les défis que nous aurons à relever dans
les prochains jours et les prochaines
semaines vous le savez sont d'une
ampleur inégalée
face à une crise virale totalement
inédite ces défis sont de plusieurs
ordres
bien sûr et premier ministre elle a
évoqué il ya la question des conditions
du déconfinement cette question qui sera
abordée plus tard et puis la question de
comment nous allons pouvoir continuer à
faire face à cette crise dans les jours
et les semaines à venir
il me revient d'aborder un certain
nombre des enjeux qui sont devant nous
tout d'abord la question des
approvisionnements sanitaires le premier
ministre l'a montré l'approvisionnement
en masque sanitaire s'est
considérablement renforcée ces dernières
semaines grâce au pont aérien aux
nombreuses commandes passées notamment
en chine et à la production à marche
forcée dans les entreprises françaises
cette augmentation qui permet de
renforcer le stock national nous a
permis ces derniers jours d'améliorer la
distribution des masques à direction
toujours du personnel soignant du
personnel le plus exposé face au virus
notamment dans les hôpitaux mais
également en médecine de ville et il me
remonte désormais d'un certain nombre de
pharmacies que la situation s'est
apaisée
je ne nie pas et je ne pourrai pas le
faire qu'il existe encore des tensions
d'approvisionnement sur des masques dits
ffp2 les masques à haut niveau de
technicité
car certain nombre de professionnels de
santé en ville voudrait pouvoir dit
voudrait pouvoir en disposer et qui ne
nous est pas encore possible de
distribuer dans des larges proportions
néanmoins les masques chirurgicaux je le
rappelle conformément aux orientations
des sociétés savantes nous permettent
d'apporter une protection à l'ensemble
des soignants
nous faisons très attention à la gestion
du stock vous le savez la situation chez
nos amis chinois est encore instable et
même si le pont aérien nous permet
d'augmenter les quantités d'un port nous
devons être vigilants et ne pas j'allais
dire dépenser ce stock de masques et
d'un coup et donc y aller
progressivement
nous allons dès cette semaine déstocker
5 millions de masques supplémentaires
par rapport à ce que nous faisons à
destination d'un certain nombre de
professionnels de santé
les ambulanciers les préparateurs en
pharmacie les sages femmes les
techniciens de laboratoire les aides à
domicile les manipulateurs radio
à terme quand nous aurons retrouvé
toutes nos capacités en termes de
masques de protection soignants nous
souhaiterons au delà même de l'apport en
masque grand public
j'y reviendrai dans quelques minutes
amener les malades à pouvoir solliciter
des masques soignants de même que les
personnes les plus fragiles ça va
prendre encore du temps ça va prendre
encore du temps et nous demandons encore
de la patience pour pouvoir répondre
pleinement à ces demandes
il ya d'autres matériels de protection
pour lesquels la situation est tendue
très clairement sur la question des
surblouse la question des charlottes la
question des tabliers parfois la
question des gants nous ne pouvons pas
répondre à toutes les demandes de la
part du profit du personnel soignant
mais nous faisons le maximum comme nous
l'avons fait sur les masques passage de
commande massive à l'étranger production
renforcée en france il y a plusieurs
plus d'un million de paires de gants qui
sera distribué cette semaine des
centaines de milliers de sur blues ces
matériaux double salon sont importants
pas aussi indispensable que les masques
de protection mais quand même important
et cette tension sur ce matériel est à
nouveau mondiale comme c'était le cas
sur les masques c'est à dire que tous
les pays du monde font face à une
demande accrue avec des capacités de
production saturé
et donc nous faisons vraiment le maximum
pour répondre aux demandes des soignants
un autre point fondamental c'est la
question des respirateurs nous vous
l'avions présenté la situation il ya
trois semaines le président de la
république était lui-même intervenu sur
cette question des respirateurs ces
matériaux ces machines qui permettent à
des malades en coma en réanimation
d'avoir une assistance respiratoire
d'ici à la fin du mois de juin la france
devrait disposer non seulement de 15000
respirateur de réanimation mais
également de 15 mille autres respirateur
plus léger qu on appelle des
respirateurs de transport c'est-à-dire
une quantité supérieure aux besoins
exprimés et aux besoins anticipé ce qui
nous permet non seulement de sécuriser
notre position mais également
d'envisager demain de mobiliser un
certain nombre de respirateurs on appuie
les partenaires de la france à
l'international
enfin un dernier point de très grande
vigilance
il reste un point de très grande
vigilance comme il les têtes déjà il ya
trois semaines
c'est la question des médicaments de
réanimation le premier ministre l'avait
dit il ya trois semaines la consommation
de médicaments notamment des curare du
midazolam sont des médicaments
indispensables pour les patients qui
sont en réanimation et placés en coma
cette consommation mondiale a pu
exploser de l'ordre de 2000 % et si la
situation sur le plan épidémique semble
s'améliorer
il a été rappelé par le professeur sall
au monde que la situation de tension
dans les hôpitaux et de saturation dans
les services de réanimation induit
encore nécessairement une consommation
très élevée de ces médicaments
et puis nous devons nous tenir prêts à
la possibilité d'une réactivation de
l'épidémie demain et donc être capable
de constituer des stocks nationaux
indispensable encore une fois pour
sauver des lits
outre la mobilisation à flux tendu des
chaînes de production de ces médicaments
sur le territoire national l'action
diplomatique est déterminante à tous
niveaux de responsabilité de l'état
auprès des principaux pays producteurs
je pense à la chine bien sûr mais aussi
à l'espagne one ou à l'inde
j'étais avant-hier au téléphone avec le
ministre indien de la santé que je
remerciais pour son autorisation
d'export d'un certain nombre de produits
génériques extrêmement utile pour nous
encore une fois cette situation n'est
pas une situation franco française elle
concerne l'ensemble des pays occidentaux
à commencer par l'europe mais également
les états unis et doit nous inviter à
une réflexion active et efficace de
réimplantation de filières de production
de ces médicaments sur nos territoires
de manière à retrouver de la
souveraineté et de lettonie et de
l'autonomie donc je le redis vigilance
très forte activisme à tous niveaux pour
pouvoir renforcer nos stocks et nos
capacités d'approvisionnement
voilà pour les ces questions
d'approvisionnement en matériel
sanitaire
je voudrais également vous parler de la
situation des ehpad ces établissements
pour personnes âgées
le professeur salomon l'a dit tout à
l'heure 45% des ehpad ont signalé au
moins un cas de coronavirus positif sur
le territoire et la mortalité vous
l'avait encore constaté tout à l'heure
est élevé ce qui se passe à l'heure où
je vous parle dans cet établissement
ainsi d'ailleurs que dans les services à
domicile parce qu'il ya au moins autant
de personnes âgées fragiles à domicile
ce qui s'y passe est à la fois poignant
est à la fois remarquable grâce au
dévouement au professionnalisme au
courage des quelques 800 mille
professionnels du grand âge qui se
battent pour leurs aînés et qu'ils
accompagnent au quotidien
depuis plusieurs semaines nous avons mis
en place des actions pour sûr pour
soutenir les ehpad d'abord ne pas
laisser un ehpad seul dans la décision
médicale et dans le soin à l'heure où je
vous parle la quasi-totalité des ehpad a
désormais accès à des permanences
spécialisées de médecine gériatrique
ensuite nous mettons tout en oeuvre pour
déployer des renforts en personnel vous
connaissez désormais la réserve
sanitaire qui mobilisait et qui le sera
encore davantage dans les semaines à
venir en direction des hôpitaux et des
ehpad
il y a également des plateformes
régionales qui permettent de mobiliser
des volontaires 1500 volontaires ont
ainsi pu être mis à disposition des
ehpad
partout des professionnels de santé ce
signal pour aider je pense par exemple
aux infirmiers scolaires mais également
aux étudiants
rien qu'en d'île de france quinze mille
étudiants infirmiers 3000 aides
soignants stagiaires ont été appelés
pour soutenir les établissements de
santé et les ehpad à chaque fois que
cela est possible
l'état met en place des dispositifs
simplifiée incitatif
par exemple en créant de nouveaux modes
de rémunération exceptionnelle
et puis il ya cette campagne de
dépistage que nous avons annoncé il ya
quelques jours
cette campagne de dépistage en ehpad qui
veut que dès qu'il ya un cas signalés
deux coronavirus dans un établissement
il faut pouvoir être capable de dépister
l'ensemble des soignants et l'ensemble
des résidents de ces ehpad je remercie
la mobilisation très forte des
collectivités locales à nos côtés mais
également des pompiers des agences
régionales de santé cette campagne bat
son plein cette semaine
cinquante mille tests cinquante mille
tests ont été programmés réalisés dans
les ehpad
ils ont évidemment pris en charge par
l'assurance maladie
un mot enfin sur les ehpad sur un sujet
qui touche les français je le sais au
coeur nous avons été amenés à demander
le confinement des personnes âgées en
ehpad et parfois même le confinement en
chambre en nous fondant sur les
recommandations des sociétés savantes et
sur l'avis éclairé du conseil
consultatif national d'éthique et nous
avons été obligés et ça a été très dur à
interdire tout droit de visite auprès
des personnes âgées dans les ehpad
tandis que le confinement est amenée à
durer encore pour plusieurs semaines
il nous a semblé utile de consulter à
nouveau les sociétés savantes les
représentants des organismes de ces
établissements pour personnes âgées et
nous avons élaboré ensemble des
recommandations nouvelles qui
permettront à partir de demain
d'organiser dans les territoires sous la
responsabilité des directions
d'établissement un droit de visite pour
les familles à direction direction de
leurs aînés fragile admis en ehpad
ce serait à la demande du résident ce
sera dans des conditions extrêmement
vous l'imaginez
limitez pas plus de deux personnes de la
famille pas tout le monde en même temps
ce sera sous la responsabilité des
directions encore une fois
d'établissement qui devront dire à la
famille lorsque ce sera possible et dans
quelles conditions
sachant que la sécurité sanitaire reste
au coeur de notre projet et qu'il y aura
donc l'impossibilité maintenu d'aller
toucher la personne d'être en contact
physique par contre il y aura un contact
visuel on peut passer beaucoup de choses
avec le regard auprès des personnes
qu'on aime et j'imagine le soulagement
qui sera celui des nombreux et dans des
nombreuses familles quand ils pourront à
nouveau rendre visite à leurs proches
souvent des personnes en perte
d'autonomie parfois désorientés mais qui
savent très bien ce que c'est que la
valeur d'un regard d'une personne
aimante
notre objectif c'est toujours de trouver
un équilibre entre sécurité et maintient
vital du lien social comme dans tous les
aspects de cette crise nous appelons
chacun à la plus grande des
responsabilités et au respect des
consignes précises qui seront données
par les professionnels j'ajoute enfin et
c'est normal que ce droit de visite très
encadrée pourra s'appliquer dans les
mêmes conditions pour les établissements
qui accueillent cette fois ci des
personnes en situation de handicap et je
m'en suis entretenu avec la secrétaire
d'état
sophie cluzel
il a les personnes qui sont fragiles et
vulnérables en ehpad il ya également les
personnes qui sont vulnérables à
domicile ce sont des centaines de
milliers de français âgés ou porteurs de
maladies chroniques pour eux on le sait
le confinement est encore plus lourd à
vivre depuis le premier jour
nous les accompagnons d'abord en
garantissant la continuité des soins
essentiels c'est la montée en puissance
de la télémédecine qui est prise en
charge à 100% par l'assurance maladie
que nous avons étendu au téléphone parce
qu'il ya des personnes notamment des
personnes âgées qui n'ont pas forcément
accès aux outils numériques et que nous
avons même étendu à d'autres professions
comme les kinésithérapeutes les
ergothérapeutes les psychomotriciens
pour les orthophonistes
c'est également la prolongation de la
durée de validité des ordonnances dans
le cadre des maladies chroniques et puis
enfin l'accompagnement médico-social si
fondamental qui a été maintenue ensuite
le gouvernement a décidé de permettre
aux actifs porteurs de maladie longue
durée de bénéficier en cas d'arrêt de
travail de la garantie de se voir
maintenir 84 % de leur salaire net c'est
même 100%
s'ils sont au smic grâce à une bascule
en activité partielle à compter du 1er
mai enfin il ne faut pas confondre mise
à l'abri et isolement
la mise à l'abri elle protège lé
isolement lui il fragilise et nous
devons lutter contre l'isolément depuis
le premier jour l'état les départements
les communes les associations les
citoyens se mobilisent pour rompre la
mise à l'abri des personnes vulnérables
c'est le repas que l'on parte ac le
repas que l'on porte ce sont les courses
que l'on fait ce sont les appels que
l'on va passer parfois au voisin au delà
le numéro vert de la plateforme qu'ovide
le 0 800 130 000 renvoi lorsque c'est
nécessaire les personnes fragiles vers
une plate forme d' écoutes qui est porté
par la croix rouge soutenu par l'état et
qui est destiné à l'ecoute au soutien à
l'orientation des personnes fragiles
mais aussi de leurs aidants pour qui la
situation est elle aussi très difficile
chaque jour ce sont plus de 20
appel qui sont ainsi orientés par
ailleurs et ce n'est pas la première
fois que nous donnons l'alertent je veux
vraiment insister ici particulièrement
sur un point le confinement ne doit pas
être synonyme de renoncement aux soins
les consultations baisses 60 % de moins
pour les consultations en médecine
spécialisée d'organes 40% de moins pour
les consultations en médecine générale
hier soir j'étais au téléphone avec un
médecin responsable syndical qui
s'inquiétaient en me disant qu'il voyait
arriver dans son cabinet depuis quelques
jours des situations qui ne pensait plus
jamais voir des hypertensions
artérielles très déséquilibré avec des
valeurs tensionnelle beaucoup trop élevé
de diabète très déséquilibrée mettant
même en péril la santé et la vie des
malades
par ailleurs on constate une baisse
inquiétante des dépistages en cancer une
baisse de la vaccination
c'est grave c'est une situation qui doit
nous inquiéter
mon message aujourd'hui il est à nouveau
double d'abord un message à destination
des malades
faites vous soigner si vous êtes porteur
d'une maladie chronique
contactez votre médecin la télémédecine
ça sert aussi à ça si vous avez peur de
vous déplacer
puis mon message il est aux médecins
mais je sais qu'il ils le font déjà
n'hésitez pas à appeler vos malades vos
patients porteurs de maladies chroniques
lorsque vous n'avez pas de nouvelles il
faut aussi être capable d'aller vers ces
malades dans cette période je rappelle
que les déplacements pour motif médical
sont autorisés les par ailleurs nous
réfléchissons à une reprise progressive
d'une activité programmée dans les
établissements de santé publics et
privés dès lors qu'ils ne mettent pas en
jeu ni les médicaments précieux destinés
aux malades en réanimation ni les
capacités de ressources humaines de
réanimation et d'anesthésié
un autre aspect rend la période
particulièrement difficile pour les
français qui sont confrontés dans cette
épreuve inédite parfois des peurs voire
parfois à de l' angoisse l'angoissent de
tomber malade
l' angoisse de perdre un proche
d'amboise du confinement
la peur de perdre son travail la peur de
perdre son commerce
parfois même va s'ajouter la peine
lorsqu'un proche est touché une peine
plus grande encore lorsqu'on perd un
parent lorsqu'on perd un ami
lorsqu'on perd un collègue une peine qui
peut être accentués par l'impossibilité
de pleurer la perte d'un être cher avec
sa famille avec ses amis et souvent même
cette impossibilité d'aller voir la
personne défunte pour les français qui
sont en souffrance des solutions
existent il est possible de consulter un
psychologue de consulter un psychiatre y
compris par télémédecine
il ya également le numéro vert que je
rappelle le 0 800 130 000
vous pouvez aussi vous appuyer sur vos
proches en ces temps de solidarité vous
voyez les témoignages se multiplient
dans traîne entre voisins des personnes
qui ne se connaissaient pas qu'ils
vivaient parfois côte à côte et qui
depuis quelques semaines on a pris
ensemble à se côtoyer à s'épauler à
s'entraider sur ces personnes d'ailleurs
que nous aurons à nous appuyer lorsqu'il
sera temps de mener une réflexion
collective en vue d'un travail de
résilience
un travail de reconstruction après cette
crise et nous aurons à retenir les
belles leçons que nous aurons donné les
français au delà je souhaite aussi
s'appuyer davantage sur les associations
qui s'occupent des personnes malades
pour plus de démocratie sanitaire pour
les soignants aussi la situation elle
est difficile au delà de la fatigue le
stress peut devenir lui aussi trop lourd
à porter j'ai lancé il ya quelques jours
une plateforme nationale à destination
de tous les soignants qui exerce à
l'hôpital en médico social en libéral
qu'ils soient d'ailleurs étudiants en
santé ou encore interne à nouveau pardon
c'est un numéro de téléphone qui leur
est accessible et d
et le 0 800 73 09 58 0 873 09 58
c'est une cellule d'écouté 7 jours sur 7
de 8 heures à minuit et qui fonctionne
grâce à l'engagement de nombreux
psychologues chaque soignant doit
pouvoir être accompagné soutenu nous y
attachons le plus grand prix le
gouvernement portent par ailleurs une
attention particulière à toutes les
situations de violence qui pourraient se
faire jour dans le cadre du confinement
et notamment de violences
intrafamiliales
enfin impossible de parler de santé
mentale sans saluer l'action remarquable
des soignants en établissement
psychiatrique où les conditions de
confinement sont encore plus difficile
qu'ailleurs et où les j'allais dire les
succès enregistrés en tout cas les
retours qui nous sont faits par les
acteurs et les soignants montre que
l'engagement est remarquable mais cela
personne n'en doutait merci monsieur le
ministre vous venez d'évoquer les défis
que nous avons à relever en matière
médicale matière thérapeutique
je voudrais que nous passions maintenant
à ce que nous ne savons pas où à ce que
nous ne savons pas encore s'agissant du
virus et à ce qui est réalisé en ce
moment comme travaux de recherche pour
évoquer ces sujets j'ai demandé à madame
la professeure florence ader qui est
infectiologue à l'hôpital de la
croix-rousse à lyon qui est responsable
coordinatrice d'un des plus vastes
essais de recherche du traitement sur le
commune
le coc vide qui s'appelle l'essai
discovery 2
de se joindre à nous cet après midi je
la remercie beaucoup d'être d'être venu
et peut-être de nous dire madame le
professeur
ce que l'on sait sur ce virus ce qu'on
ne sait pas il peut être aussi
d'expliquer à nos concitoyens
comment on cherche ok dure mission fort
merci monsieur le ministre
donc effectivement joue je m'appelle
florence adhère chez infectiologue à
l'hôpital de lyon dans le service de
maladies infectieuses du professeur
chidiac avec une extraordinaire équipe
que je salue au passage
et ce qui est en jeu ce qui est
intéressant le fait d'être ici et de
pouvoir échanger avec vous c'est que je
vous explique un petit peu qu'on fasse à
une sorte de dover view de tour
d'horizon des actions de recherche qu'on
mène actuellement
alors qu'est ce que l'on sait sur qu'est
ce que l'on sait sur le virus et il ya
un certain nombre de choses qui vous ont
déjà été expliqué il ya trois semaines
mais on progresse à la vitesse de
l'éclair on va très vite
actuellement dans la recherche la
structure du virus on commence à bien la
connaître
la carte d'identité du virus
c'est-à-dire le génome du virus aussi
est connu on connaît un certain nombre
de choses qui permettent au virus de
s'attacher aux cellules ça c'est très
important parce que c'est sa porte
d'entrée on progresse aussi beaucoup
dans la description des formes cliniques
de la maladie
et ça c'est important que nous sur le
terrain on soit parfaitement au courant
de tout ça parce que ça permet
d'écourter les temps diagnostic dans la
mesure où on est assez vigilants un
certain nombre de symptômes que l'on
décrit au fil de vos la chronologie de
la maladie par conséquent est désormais
assez bien connu et puis ce qui est très
important parce que il n'ya pas
d'infection sens la réponse du système
immunitaire c'est impossible que il
pas une étude coordonnée de l'impact du
virus et de la réponse du système
immunitaire et si on fait la somme de
toutes ces connaissances qui ont été
acquises ça nous a pris moins de quatre
mois pour apprendre tout ça c'est donc
absolument extraordinaire parce que si
on y met si on se projette dans ce qu'il
a pu se passer par exemple au moment de
l'épidémie vih on a mis plusieurs années
à acquérir la somme de connaissances
qu'on connaît actuellement déjà sur le
coronavirus après évidemment et encore
des choses qu'on va apprendre la
disparité hommes-femmes pourquoi plus
d'hommes sont infectés pourquoi plus
d'hommes sont hospitalisés question à
laquelle pour l'instant on ne peut pas
vraiment répondre l'autre l'autre
questionnement c'est la gravité il est
très difficile d'anticiper actuellement
les patients qui vont développer des
formes graves
en comparaison aux patients qui vont
développer des formes moins graves qui
nécessiterait qui ne nécessiterait pas
par exemple d'être hospitalisée ce qui
en hospitalisation vont se dégrader
l'impact sur l'enfant les enfants sont
relativement peu touchés avec des formes
symptomatiques peu importante
je reprends mes jeux presque la personne
n'osera la lamelle alors ça c'est une
question extrêmement importante
la maladie n'est a priori peut-être pas
immunisante et ça c'est une question
pour l'instant laquelle nous ne sommes
pas capables de répondre en l'occurrence
quand j'ai fait la maladie une fois est
ce que j'ai la possibilité si je suis de
nouveau en contact de développer des
symptômes est de nouveau d'être malade
donc si on passe à la
à la diapositive suivante la façon dont
à partir de là nous on raisonne comment
est ce qu'on peut proposer des choses
en période de crise c'est à dire dans
une séquence tenté extrêmement courte
alors la façon dont on a résonné en
première intention c'est de dire ok
c'est un virus
nous possédons des médicaments
antiviraux un certain nombre d'entre eux
et pas que des médicaments antiviraux
ont une activité potentielle sur ce
virus est la question c'est de les
tester
donc on a mené un certain nombre de
travaux in vitro c'est à dire dans la
dans un laboratoire et on a retenu un
certain nombre de molécules qui étaient
des molécules qu'on a utilisées dans le
vih par exemple une autre molécule qui a
déjà été testé dans ebola ou dans le
mercosur d'un virus qui est un autre
type de couronnes un virus et puis on a
testé d'autres drogues qui ne sont pas
nécessairement des drogues et des
médicaments utilisés dans le cadre des
infections virales et notamment la
chloroquine et lead roxy chloroquine qui
sont des médicaments qu'on utilise dans
le paludisme alors là on tombe sur
d'accord très bien on utilise ces
médicaments là on va faire des essais
cliniques avec ces médicaments là mais
comme nous ne sommes pas dans
l'indication initiale
il ne faut absolument pas niveler tout
l'aspect réglementaire des essais et
c'est pour ça qu'on a été extrêmement
exigeants par rapport par exemple pour
les laisser discovery dont on que je
pilote
on a été extrêmement exigeants sur la
réglementation c'est à dire le comité de
protection des personnes pour avoir tous
les feux verts pour mener ces essais et
bien sûr l'autorisation de l'agencé
nationale de sécurité du médicament
actuellement cet essai par exemple a
inclus pas loin de 700 patients avec un
objectif qui est au moins de 800
patients et sept essais et aux également
année c'est européen international et
donc on va avoir des résultats qui
seront certainement intéressant en
revanche le corollaire à ça c'est que si
on utilise des médicaments qui ne sont
pas directement design
conçu pour le virus il ya fort à parier
que ces molécules là que ces médicaments
là ne soient pas les médicaments
miracles
l'autre point que je tiens à souligner
c'est qu'effectivement quand je vous ai
expliqué tout à l'heure que certains
patients avaient des critères de gravité
on peut aussi utiliser les médicaments
qui diminue l'inflammation liés à ce
virus
alors donc la mobilisation elle est
absolument mondiale sur la recherche en
matière de cornet virus c'est pour ça
que ça va aussi vite et c'est vrai qu'en
france si on regarde la cartographie un
peu de tout de tout et de tous les
essais en cours
on voit bien que c'est réparti très
harmonieusement sur tout le territoire
et que tout le monde s'est retroussé les
manches et que par conséquent la
recherche active du contre le
coronavirus est extrêmement vivace en
france dernière diapositives dans jour
et sur laquelle voudrais attirer votre
attention ça c'est une notion
extrêmement importante on a parlé tout à
l'heure de la recherche quasiment en
première ligne en première intention
où on utilise des molécules qu'on
connaît déjà des médicaments que l'on
connaît déjà
l'idée c'est que quand on progresse et
qu'on comprend beaucoup mieux la façon
dont le virus est structuré la façon
dont il fonctionne et la façon dont il
interagit avec l'organisme ça vous
permet à ce moment là d'avoir des
stratégies complètement spécifique aux
virus et c'est ça aboutit à deux
innovations qui sont d'une part et qui
sont extrêmement importantes et qui sont
en cours actuellement qui sont d'une
part de trouver des cibles qui nous
permettent d'élaborer de nouveaux
médicaments mais qui sont complètement
spécifique à ce virus
donc ça c'est des médicaments dits de
deuxième génération et on est déjà dans
cette dynamique là et bien sûr le graal
c'est de trouver un vaccin des vaccins
qui soit assez spécifique pour générer
une réponse immunitaire qui soit
complètement ciblées sur ce virus
premier point deuxième point qui génère
une immunité qui soit durable dans le
temps et on revient sur cette question
de si je suis re confrontée au vide dû
au virus
est-ce que je peux éventuellement
développer la maladie c'est
potentiellement sq empêcherait un vaccin
donc il ya des tas de vaccin en
développement actuellement dans le monde
en particulier à l'institut pasteur où
il ya un vaccin dont les essais chez
l'homme vont commencer à échéance de cet
été merci beaucoup
même le professeur pour cette
présentation très clair fait un sujet
qui est redoutablement technique pour
ceux qui ne qui n'ont pas la formation
médicale qui est qu est la vôtre
le défi de soins on l'a vu le défi de la
recherche
on vient de le voir les défis auxquels
nous faisons face c'est aussi la partie
économique de de la difficulté que nous
connaissons le risque économique
associée à la crise sanitaire que nous
vivons sont considérables d'ores et déjà
il est acquis que l'impact de cette
crise sanitaire ce sera la plus forte
récession connue en france et dans le
monde occidental depuis 1945
nous projetons que au cours de l'année
2020 la croissance sera négative de
l'ordre de -8%
on a souvent l'occasion de se demander
qu'est ce que ça veut dire une
croissance de 1% ou 1 et demi pour cent
ou 2 % parfois et on se réjouit quand la
croissance est importante moins 8% de
croissance en 2020 ça veut dire que la
richesse nationale face aux contracté
qu'elle va diminuer de l'ordre de près
de 10% cette quelque chose de jamais vu
qui va avoir un impact considérable et
quelques chiffres que vous voyez sur
l'écran sont éloquents au total c'est
près de moi 36 % d'activité économique
pendant la période de confinement une
diminution de l'activité dans
l'industrie de l'ordre de 43%
une diminution de l'activité dans le
domaine de la construction dont on
connaît l'importance pour la vie
économique nationale de l'ordre de 88 %
et une quasi cessation générales
d'activité dans la restauration dans les
cafés dans les hôtels
pour la plus grande majorité d'entre eux
ce choc économique
il est propre à la france mais en
réalité il est propre à tous les pays
qui sont confrontées à l'épidémie c'est
vrai en italie c'est vrai en espagne
c'est vrai au royaume uni c'est vrai aux
états unis et c'est vrai dans un très
grand nombre de pays qui alors même que
l'épidémie ne les frappe pas directement
ou avec moins d'intensité voit néanmoins
l'impact de la fin de l'activité ou de
la cessation d'activité dans d'autres
pays se diffuser vers eux n'ayant plus
de marché ils ne peuvent plus produire
et là aussi les affaires s'arrête
l'objectif du gouvernement dans cette
période c'est de sauvegarder ce qui peut
l'être aujourd'hui pour permettre de
relancer demain ce qui doit l'être
l'idée au fond et est assez simple c'est
la réalisation qui est difficile nous
devons faire en sorte de ne pas perdre
aujourd'hui tout notre tissu productif
de lui permettre de passer cette crise
sanitaire de passer cet obstacle pour
pouvoir demain rebondir repartir de
l'avant
c'est exactement pour cela que nous
avons mis en place un certain nombre
d'instruments qui ont été adoptées par
le parlement à l'occasion de la première
loi de finances rectificative et qui ont
été complétés qui sont en train d'être
complété par le parlement à l'issue de
la deuxième loi de finances
rectificative
d'abord un instrument qui n'avaient
jamais été mises en oeuvre dans ces
conditions en france qu'on appelle
parfois le chômage partiel qui est en
vérité un instrument qui permet de
poursuivre l'activité est de faire en
sorte que l'entreprise ne licencie pas
ses salariés alors même qu'elle ne peut
plus fonctionner ce dispositif de
chômage partiel que nous avons mis en
place concerne aujourd'hui plus de 700
mille entreprises
au fond c'est presque une entreprise sur
deux qui en bénéficie est presque un
salarié sur deux qui en bénéficient
c'est évidemment absolument considérable
et le dispositif que nous avons mis en
place
instruit d'ailleurs par l'expérience de
2008 c'est-à-dire de la crise financière
est un dispositif généreux
qui permet à l'entreprise de ne pas
perdre ses salariés et qui permet au
salarié de conserver une rémunération de
l'ordre de 84 % du salaire net
ce qui est très important plus important
que tous les autres systèmes mis en
place dans les pays comparables
9 millions de salariés je les dis c'est
un coup un budget global de l'ordre de
24 milliards d'euros c'est absolument
considérable mais c'est ce qui va nous
permettre de ne pas faire basculer
brutalement et inexorablement une partie
considérable de nos concitoyens dans le
chômage
juste un chiffre qui a évidemment une
porte et non pas de comparaison car les
deux pays sont difficilement comparables
mais qui doit être pris en compte par
nos concitoyens en un mois aux etats
unis 22 millions de travailleurs ont
basculé dans le chômage en à moi 22
millions de chômeurs en plus le deuxième
instrument que nous avons mis en place
sont des prêts garantis par l'état il
s'agit de faire en sorte que le système
bancaire puisse continuer à prêter aux
entreprises qui pour qu'elle puisse
continuer à fonctionner le risque que
nous avons anticipé ce serait celui que
la circulation de l'argent s'arrête si
les entreprises ne peuvent pas
bénéficier d'emprunt elles peuvent se
trouver du jour au lendemain en
cessation de paiement et donc devoir
s'arrêter pour lutter contre cela nous
avons garanti les emprunts consentis par
les banques aux entreprises
cent trente mille entreprises en sont
déjà bénéficiaires
nous avons conçu une enveloppe globale
de 300 milliards d'euros est d'ores et
déjà c'est plus de 18 milliards d'euros
qui ont été distribués garantie 7
le signe que nous pouvons accompagner
les entreprises pour qu' elle soit
sauvegardée pendant la crise afin de
pouvoir repartir demain
enfin un fonds de solidarité pour toutes
celles des petites entreprises voire des
très petites entreprises de moins de dix
salariés
à ce stade qu'ils ne s'en sortiront pas
si ceux qui les font vivre ne reçoivent
pas un versement de solidarité parce
qu'elles ne pourront pas être sauvés
sans ce versement nous avons là aussi
prévu un dispositif large à hauteur de 7
milliards d'euros qui a permis de
traiter dans des conditions très rapide
plus d'un million de demandes reçues
c'est l'état à travers les direction
générale des finances publiques qui a
versé directement dans les quatre ou
cinq jours qui suivaient la demande
reçue les sommes aux entreprises
ces 7 milliards d'euros sont financés
pour l'essentiel par l'état mais je veux
indiquer que les assureurs se sont
engagés à participer à hauteur de 400
millions d'euros à ce budget est que les
régions se sont engagés à participer à
hauteur de 500 millions d'euros à ce
fonds de solidarité
c'est la réponse pour sauvegarder
aujourd'hui mais bien entendu il faudra
relancer demain et lorsque la crise
sanitaire sera passée lorsque nous
allons reprendre l'activité
nous devrons penser à un plan de relance
national européen sans doute de façon à
faire repartir la machine ce qui sera
indispensable
à côté de ces mesures d'urgence
économique il y a évidemment des mesures
d'urgence sociale parce que le
confinement et la difficulté économique
peuvent plonger les plus fragiles
d'entre nous dans des difficultés
absolument considérable c'est la raison
pour laquelle le gouvernement a décidé
de mettre en oeuvre des mesures
d'urgence sociale je vais laisser le
ministre de la santé et des solidarités
présenté ses mesures d'urgence sociale
oui on le sait la préquelle la précarité
elle accentue toujours l'impact des
crises et là on imagine très bien une
famille qui ne peut plus mettre ses
enfants à la cantine qui fait des
courses à la supérette du coin et ça
peut coûter plus cher
parfois c'est le petit boulot qui
permettait d'avoir un appoint financier
à la fin du mois qui ne peut plus être
là et donc ça expose plus durablement et
vous avez certainement en tête ces
images dans certains pays de files
indiennes continuent de personnes qui
font la queue pour pouvoir avoir
l'approvisionnement alimentaire en
france on a comme on a quand même un
système de protection sociale qui joue
le rôle d'amortisseur et qui vit et qui
le joue à plein et nous avons pris le
gouvernement a pris des décisions
immédiates le maintien des prestations
sociales pour tous ceux qui en
bénéficiaient avant la crise du coc vide
de façon automatique sans démarche la
prolongation de la trêve hivernale pour
les sans abri le ministre du logement et
de la ville julien de normandie à
déterminer 17 mille places d'hébergement
d'urgence 64 mille tickets services ont
été distribués ainsi aux personnes qui
n'ont pas de logement et vous imaginez
que le confinement
quand on n'a pas de logement c'est
encore plus compliqué avec christelle du
boss un travail important a été fait
également avec les associations en lien
avec les publics précaires pour garantir
le maintien de prestations sociales et
le premier ministre a annoncé ce
mercredi en sortie des conseils du
conseil des ministres une prime
exceptionnelle
enfin une aide exceptionnelle de
solidarité qui sera versé le 15 mai à
venir sans aucune démarche et qui va
concerner quatre millions de foyers 4
millions de ménages c'est une prime qui
sera vert
et aux allocataires du rsa et de la ss à
raison de 150 euros par bénéficiaire est
également une allocation de 100 euros
par enfant qui sera versée à tous les
bénéficiaires du rsa de la ss mais
également aux bénéficiaires des apl ça
veut dire que pour une famille au rsa
une personne au rsa avec trois enfants
percevra une aide exceptionnelle de 450
euros
ce 15 mai c'est une mesure
supplémentaire pour accompagner les
personnes précaires la liste serait très
longue de toutes les mesures qui ont été
prises par le gouvernement depuis le
début de cette crise mais encore une
fois c'est la fierté de notre pays que
de pouvoir compter sur un modèle de
protection sociale que beaucoup vraiment
beaucoup nous envient
alors à côté de l'ensemble de ces défis
l'urgence sociale et l'urgence
économique l'urgence de la recherche
urgence des soins il y à la perspective
pour beaucoup de nos concitoyens pour
nous tous en vérité de ce qui a été
appelé le déconfinement de ce qui
pourrait être utilement appelé me
semble-t-il la phase suivante
car comme je le disais au début de mon
propos le déconfinement ce n'est pas le
retour à la situation qui prévalait
avant ce n'est pas le retour à une vie
totalement normal voit une vie où tout
pourrait s'effectuer dans les mêmes
conditions que celles qui prévalaient un
mois avant le confinement c'est un
mécanisme plus progressif et pour non
pas en préciser tous les détails car ce
sera l'objet du plan que j'annoncerai
dans les quinze jours qui viennent pour
en fixer les principes et en définir un
peu le cadre je voudrais d'abord
commencé à dire quels sont les principes
que nous voulons observer dans le cadre
du déconfinement
la première priorité c'est préserver la
santé des français nous avons procédé au
confinement pour préserver la santé des
français et par définition nous allons
sortir progressivement du confinement en
respectant cette impératifs de
préservation de la santé des français
le deuxième principe qui est également
très important même si j'ai parfaitement
conscience qu'il peut lorsqu'il est
formulée comme je vais le formuler être
compris de façon un peu théorique
il s'agit d'assurer la continuité de la
vie de la nation qu'est ce que ça veut
dire assurer la continuité de la vie de
la nation
c'est garantir que nous allons pouvoir
continuer à produire pour nourrir pour
avoir accès à l'énergie pour nous
transporter que nous allons pouvoir
continuer à préparer les générations
futures aux responsabilités qui seront
les leurs que nous allons pouvoir faire
continuer continuer l'école la
solidarité l'investissement
tous ces éléments qui sont constitutifs
de la vie de la nation et que nous ne
pouvons pas comme je lé indéfiniment
sous peine de voir la nation
s'effondrait préserver la santé des
français
assurer la continuité de la nation voilà
les principes qui doivent nous guider
dans le déconfinement et nous devons
respecter ou plus exactement
nous devons suivre deux conditions qui
sont essentiels la première c'est
rétablir la capacité d'accueil des
hôpitaux nous avons décidé le
confinement pour faire en sorte que
cette capacité d'accueil des hôpitaux ne
soit pas déborder ce qui conduirait un
désastre sanitaire
nous devons veiller à ce que dans le
déconfinement cette capacité d'accueil
des hôpitaux ne soit pas à nouveau
soumise à une pression considérable
voire débordé la deuxième condition le
deuxième chose que nous devons avoir en
tête et qui va évidemment directement
avec la capacité d'accueil des hôpitaux
c'est la circulation du virus nous
allons devoir faire en sorte de limiter
au maximum la circulation
virus pour limiter au maximum le nombre
d'infections est donc le nombre de cas
sévères et les deux ensemble nous
permettre d'envisager le chemin du
déconfinement tamment peut-être parce
que il ya trois semaines nous avions
évoqué ce concept un peu technique mais
absolument essentiel qu'on appelle le
zéro c'est à dire au fond pour le dire
dans des termes plus triviale si j'ose
dire le nombre de personnes qu'un malade
infecte la transmission de la maladie à
partir d'un malade vers combien de
malades
si on ne fait rien parce que cette
maladie est assez contagieuse on observe
un taux de l'ordre de 3 à 4
certains disent même un peu plus je ne
veux pas rentrer dans les polémiques
scientifique mais on constate que ce
chiffre est élevé pour réduire le nombre
de cas pour réduire l'épidémie
il faut que le r0 le nombre de malades
nouveaux infectés par un malade soit
égal à 1 ou inférieure à 1
c'est comme ça que nous sommes capables
de réduire la circulation du virus de
réduire le nombre de cas est donc
d'éteindre l'épidémie progressivement
grâce au confinement
les épidémiologistes les experts
considèrent que nous avons réussi à
faire diminuer le r0 de l'ordre de à le
faire passer à une valeur de 0,6 ce qui
veut dire que 10 malades n'affecte que
six nouvelles personnes
c'est remarquable et c'est évidemment un
élément qui nous permet de dire que
l'épidémie ralentit et ralentit
fortement ce que nous voyons dans les
admissions à l'hôpital
ce que nous constatons à la fin je
dirais de l'évolution de la maladie
notre objectif c'est de faire en sorte
au moment du des confirmands à partir du
11 mai que le nombre de malades soit
limité et que la circulation du virus
le nombre de nouveaux malades
susceptibles d'intervenir à partir du 11
mai soit également limité que le r0
reste égale ou inférieure
1 ça ce sont les principes du
déconfinement ce sont les objectifs que
nous nous fixons et je veux le dire le
fait de rester dans cette situation de
confinement
jusqu'au 11 mai nous permet d'aborder le
déconfinement dans de meilleures
conditions c'est aussi une des raisons
pour lesquelles le président de la
république a décidé de poursuivre cette
période de confinement jusqu'au 11 mai
la deuxième idée qu'il faut avoir en
tête et qui est une idée importante et
qui n'est pas forcément une idée
réjouissante
c'est que nous allons devoir apprendre à
vivre avec le virus
non pas que nous l'acceptions non pas
que nous ayons baisser les bras face à
l'épidémie au contraire mais parce que
nous constatons que la population n'est
pas immunisée
le sera t elle un jour cela dépendra de
ce qu'a dit madame le professeur de ce
que la science sera déterminé c'est à
dire des caractéristiques de la maladie
mais quoi qu'il en soit aujourd'hui la
population n'est pas immunisée
la circulation du virus a été
suffisamment restreinte pour qu' un
nombre trop limité de personnes étaient
en contact avec le virus et donc la
population n'est pas immunisée on
considère que les modèles qui sont en
train d'être retravaillé et va lui être
deux à 6 millions le nombre de nos
concitoyens qui sont entrés en contact
avec le virus
on est très loin de ce qu'on appelle
parfois l'immunité de de masse ou
l'immunité populationnelle la population
n'est pas immunisée
nous n'aurons pas de vaccin rapidement
en tout cas rien à un horizon
raisonnable avant 2021 est peut-être un
peu plus loin il n'y a pas à ce stade de
traitements efficaces démontrer ou
connue même si la recherche est
évidemment intense et même si les
scientifiques les médecins sont
déterminés et optimistes sur leur
capacité à trouver un traitement
aujourd'hui et dans un avenir proche en
tout cas il n'y a pas encore de
traitement connu cela nous laisse un
instrument la prévention qui va être
déterminante dans la façon dont nous
allons procéder aux déconfinement dans
la façon dont nous allons vivre après le
confinement vivre avec le virus
cette prévention fait façon de lutter
contre la circulation du virus va
reposer sur trois éléments essentiels et
c'est ce que je veux indiquer avant de
passer la parole au ministre de la santé
d'abord les gestes barrière vous les
connaissez ils sont absolument
essentielles et ne pas les respecter
les prendre avec un peu plus de facilité
un peu plus de décontraction
parce que ça fait longtemps parce qu'on
a entendu quelques bonnes nouvelles
c'est littéralement nous exposer à une
reprise de l'épidémie à une reprise de
la circulation et de l'accélération de
la circulation du virus
nous allons donc devoir vie
avec le respect de gestes barrières de
mesures barrières sur lesquels le
ministre va revenir c'est le premier
aspect indispensable le deuxième aspect
ce sont les tests et singulièrement les
tests virologiques
le ministre y reviendra pour pouvoir
vivre avec le virus pour pouvoir
recommencer à vivre normalement si j'ose
dire avec ce virus qui circulent nous
allons devoir tester et testé vite et
massivement tous ceux qui sont
susceptibles de le porter tous ceux qui
présentent des symptômes ou qui ont été
en contact avéré avec présenteraient des
symptômes et qui ont été contact avéré
avec un malade
nous allons devoir tester beaucoup vite
rapidement et le troisième élément qui
accompagne cette politique celle
isolement des porteurs du virus
si nous ne mettons pas en oeuvre ces
trois axes alors nous avons une
politique incomplète les seuls gestes
barrières ne suffisent pas et nous
connaissons des pays pourtant très bien
organisés dans lesquelles les gestes
barrières sont observés avec une rigueur
et un civisme qui font parfois envie et
qui pourtant alors même qu'ils portent
des masques
alors même qu'ils respectent les gestes
barrière voix l'épidémie se développer
et s'accélérer sur leur territoire ce
qui les conduit pour certains d'entre
eux a procédé au confinement les gestes
barrières les tests rapides et
l'isolément de ceux qui sont regardés
comme porteurs du virus
c'est sur ces trois éléments que nous
allons organiser notamment le plan de
déconfinement que je présenterai dans
deux semaines mais je veux dire quelques
éléments sur chacun de ces trois grands
axes barrière test isolement des
porteurs je vais laisser le ministre des
solidarités de la santé évoqué la
question des gestes barrières et des
tests et je reviendrai sur la question
de l'isolément
sur les questions d des gestes barrières
si un consensus international jamais
pris à défaut
intangible c'est l'importance du lavage
des mains d'éviter de tous et vers les
personnes qui sont face à vous en
préférant tousser dans son coude
utilisez un mouchoir à usage unique et
donc le jeter une fois que vous l'avez
utiliser auquel on a ajouté depuis crépy
en valois le fait de ne pas serrer la
main de ne pas se faire la bise de
garder ce qu'on appelle la distanciation
physique au moins 1 m ce sont les
meilleurs outils pour se prémunir d'un
virus qui peut être transmis certes par
des particules des gouttelettes mais
aussi énormément et la plupart du temps
d'ailleurs par la transmission par les
mains donc ça les gestes barrière c'est
pour vous protéger pour les protéger
pour nous protéger
c'est intangible et probablement que on
apprend collectivement à faire face à
des épidémies et des virus et que ces
gestes barrières on sera amenés
probablement en conserver en tout cas
une partie d'entre eux dans d'autres
périodes d'épidémie notamment les
épidémies grippales
je crois que maintenant tout le monde
enfin pleinement pris conscience de
l'importance de les appliquer dans notre
pays il ya une autre mesure de
protection qui fait c'est normal
beaucoup parlé et qui pose beaucoup
question qu'ils posent beaucoup question
dans la communauté scientifique fou
trouver des publications qui sont
favorables d'autres qui sont plutôt
circonspect tu vous avez des autorités
sanitaires françaises et étrangères qui
sont amenés à prendre des positions je
parlais bien sûr de la question des
masques et au delà de la question des
masques soignants de ce que nous avons
appelé les masques grand public
ces masses qui ne remplaceront jamais
les gestes barrières et porter un masque
grand public et considérer qu on peut
donc toucher l'autre ou parler à moins
d'un mètre ou éviter de tousser dans son
coude serait une erreur ce que nous
disent les autorités y compris
d'ailleurs au niveau de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
est ce que le masque grand public peut
participer à l'arsenal des mesures
visant à nous protéger d'une épidémie
les autorités donc une scientifique sont
en train d'évaluer les choses certaines
évolué d'autres pas encore peut-être
évolueront elle en attendant et sans
attendre surtout l'état français dès le
début du mois de mars a mobilisé et
l'immobilisation formidable les
industriels du textile pour aller
fabriquer des masques destinés au grand
public ce ne sont donc pas les masques
chirurgicaux dit les masques ffp2 mais
ce sont tout de même des masques qui
répondent à des normes
ces normes elles disent qu au delà
d'être évidemment respirable ces masques
permettent de filtrer des gouttelettes
qui contiennent du virus et pour éviter
que les villes les gouttelettes ne
rentrer chez eux aussi éviter si vous
êtes malade que des gouttelettes ne
sorte je disais cette masse qui
répondent à des normes parce qu'on sait
qu'ils garantissent un niveau
d'efficacité intéressant il ya huit
millions de masques qui ont été produits
de la semaine écoulée dans notre pays on
prévoit une production d'environ 17
millions de masques par semaine en
france grâce à l'action vont encore une
fois remarquable et de réorientation de
l'industrie très rapide avec les chaînes
de montage très rapide de plus d'une
centaine d'entreprises sur notre
territoire et en plus la france importe
en grande quantité des masques qui
correspondent à ces normes
vous les verrez bientôt ils sont en
tissu la majorité d'entre eux sont
lavables et réutilisables jeu certains
cinq fois d'autres vins foies d'autres
même trente fois réutilisables
la question que se posent les français
sait quelles seront les modalités de
déploiement
on peut imaginer qu'il y ait un amorçage
qu'ils soient faits par l'état à
destination notamment des personnes et
des professionnels des gens qui
travaillent au contact
les français et puis encouragé la
capacité des collectivités
évidemment très importante ravis avec
les mairies notamment sur cette question
de la distribution
et pourquoi pas de la grande
distribution d'être capable aussi de
participer à cet effort pour pouvoir
équiper les français qui le souhaiteront
avec parfois des conditions de port du
masque qui seront pour reprendre les
mots du président de la république
systématiser encore une fois ça ne
remplacera pas les gestes barrière mais
ça peut être un outil intéressant et
c'est pourquoi la france n'a pas attendu
pour pouvoir entraîner la fabrication
autre point très important le premier
ministre en parlait c'est la question
des tests
vous savez le ms dit désormais tester
tester tester et nous avons augmenté
progressivement nos capacités de test
d'abord juste un mot pour vous chacun
comprenne
il y a deux sortes de tests il ya le
test viral qui est le test qui permet de
savoir au moment où on fait le test
si vous êtes porteur du virus si vous
êtes malade avec ou sans symptômes
c'est ce qu'on appelle le test pcr c'est
une grosse logistique une grosse
plateforme généralement hospitalière
mais également aussi maintenant en
laboratoire de ville et vous l'avez sans
doute suivie même les laboratoires qui
ne sont pas destinés aux humains comme
les laboratoires vétérinaires les
laboratoires de recherche gendarmerie
tous ceux qui sont capables de faire ces
tests sont pleinement mobilisés sur tout
le territoire
ce tests virologiques il est important
et il serait encore plus important au
moment du décompte final
si vous êtes porteur de symptômes on est
après le 11 mai et que vous voulez
savoir si vous êtes malade ou si vous
avez été qu'un contact rapproché d'une
personne dont on sait qu'elle est malade
vous pouvez vous devrez bénéficier de ce
tests virologiques qui vous dire à un
moment vous le fait encore une fois si
vous êtes malade mais ça vous dira pas
si vous étiez malade il ya dix jours il
ya deux semaines nous il ya trois
semaines donc ça vraiment un intérêt
diagnostic et puis les tests
sérologiques le test sérologique
c'est un test qui permet de savoir si
vous êtes porteur des anticorps les
anticorps c'est si vous voulez le
résultat de votre le professeur en
parlais tout à l'heure
les dates de la mémoire immunitaire
quand vous avez été exposé un virus vous
avez développé des armes contre ce virus
qu'on appelle des anticorps et vous
pouvez les garder en mémoire et la
sérologie elle permet de savoir si oui
ou non vous avez ces anticorps mais vous
avez bien écouter le professeur adhère
tout à l'heure et elle vous a dit qu'il
ya beaucoup de questions qui se posent
autour de cette mémoire
au bout de combien de temps après avoir
contracté la maladie les anticorps
apparaissent est-ce que s ils sont
apparus est-ce qu'ils vont rester tout
le temps où est-ce qu'ils vont
disparaître
et puis tout simplement est ce que ces
anticorps hills ils veulent dire qu'on
est protégée contre la maladie ou non
tant qu'on n'a pas répondu à ces
questions tant que personne au monde n'a
pu apporter une réponse ferme à ces
questions considéré qu'il faille
s'appuyer massivement sur les tests
sérologiques serait anticipée une
situation qui risque de ne pas coller à
la réalité alors que les tests pcr ça on
sait que pour pouvoir dépister les
malades et ensuite isolés c'est
fondamental la recherche avance on
n'attend pas que la recherche est avancé
pour travailler industrialisés et nous
équiper en test sérologique
mais encore une fois grande prudence sur
ce que nous pourrons faire de ces tests
et je le dis parce que il y a des
formidable initiative et on peut les
comprendre qu'ils partent de la part des
entreprises parfois des collectivités et
qui veulent s'équiper en test parfois
des tests sérologiques il peut y avoir
la confusion encore une fois entre les
deux types de tests certains tests
proviennent de pays où ils ont été
fabriqués mais une correspondent à
aucune norme ils n'ont pas été validés
par aucun laboratoire français de sorte
que non seulement on n'est pas sûr qu'il
soit utile mais en plus on n'est pas sûr
que ces tests soient efficaces certains
d'entre eux ont 40% de faux négatifs
c'est-à-dire que vous avez presque une
chance sur deux de ne pas être détectées
quand bien même vous ferez ce test
sérologique
c'est sûr que demain dans la paire de
déconfinement tout le monde tout le
monde aura un rôle à jouer dans la
répartition des masques dans le test on
va faire une politique
déclinée sur les territoires avec des
équipes mobiles on va s'appuyer sur
toutes les bonnes volontés parce que
l'objectif il est majeur mais attention
de ne pas aller trop vite et de ne pas
mettre à disposition des français du
matériel qui pourrait au contraire
fragiliser notre campagne de tests cette
campagne en deux chiffres
25000 c'est le nombre de tests que nous
réalisons chaque jour aujourd'hui
probablement encore un peu sous-évalué
parce qu'il est compliqué de faire le
dans le détail de tous les laboratoires
de villes qui font des tests les données
ne nous remonte pas au quotidien
annonçait que c'est aux alentours de 25
mille tonnes par jour et un deuxième
chiffre c'est 500 milles
cette fois ci c'est le nombre de tests
par semaine que nous souhaitons être en
mesure de faire au moment du des
confirmands le 11 mai vous savez qu'à
logistique et complexes qu'il en va des
kits de production des échos villon del
rey actif des choses que vous lisez dans
la presse et c'est tout à fait normal
parce que c'est quelque chose qui
mobilise les français croyez-moi ça
mobilise aussi tous les sites ou les
chercheurs tous les soignants
toutes les usines de production est
évidemment le gouvernement est très
mobilisés pour réussir cet objectif de
500 mille tests par semaine d'ici au 11
mai et pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut tester
parce qu'il faut pouvoir casser les
chaînes de transmission du virus
c'est toute la logique de la politique
de santé qui va être mise en place sur
tout le territoire national
au moment du décompte final vous avez un
symptôme vous pouvez tester peut tester
dans un drive ou peut être testé sur un
parking où est testée dans un
laboratoire de ville ou à l'hôpital vous
devez être testés
si vous êtes positif vous êtes
immédiatement alertés et la s'enclenche
une mécanique qui fait appel à la
mobilisation de beaucoup de personnes
ce sera pas forcément d'ailleurs des
soignants il va falloir beaucoup de
personnes beaucoup de citoyens de gens
formés pour être capable non seulement
de prendre contact avec vous de vous
avertir mais également de faire du twr a
thing c'est à dire d'aller regarder tous
les cas contacter toutes les personnes
que vous avez pu croiser côtoyé pendant
suffisamment de temps à distance
suffisamment proche pour risquer d'avoir
contaminé sept personnes évidemment sans
le vouloir et donc ça nécessite une
logistique humaine très forte très forte
mobilisés sur tout le territoire ça
mobilise aussi sans doute des systèmes
d'information son appel les sytèmes
informations c1 comment est ce que le
numérique
comment est-ce que les applications
peuvent aider les personnes humaines à
répertorier toutes les personnes malades
toutes les personnes contacts rapprochés
des personnes malades pour casser les
chaînes de transmission du virus et être
capables ensuite d'isoler les personnes
malade et de dépister tout le monde ces
outils numériques
on est en train et vous le savez de
mener une réflexion pas que française
européenne et même mondiale
il y aura un débat parlementaire qui
aura lieu le 28 avril à l'assemblée
nationale le 29 avril au sénat parce que
c'est important parce que ça concerne
les libertés individuelles et
collectives même si le gouvernement a
déjà annoncé que ces outils numériques
il serait sur la base du volontariat
ils seraient anonymisés et en aucun cas
ne constitueraient des contraintes mais
ça peut être utile
il faut voir dans quelles conditions
dans quelles proportions encore une fois
pour toutes cette politique de tests de
détection d'extension des dépistages et
ensuite d'isolement les mesures
barrières pour éviter de propager le
virus des tests pour identifier le plus
tôt possible
ceux qui sont porteurs du virus et
ensuite l'isolément de ceux qui sont
porteurs du virus pour éviter qu'ils ne
transmettent eux mêmes le virus a de
nouveau proche moins proche et que donc
l'épidémie perdure ou se développe
l'idée ce sera de dire dès que des
symptômes apparaissent test si vous êtes
testé positif c'est à dire si vous êtes
porteur du virus
vous aurez le choix entre un isolement
un confinement à domicile qui fera
forcément peser sur vous et sur
l'ensemble de ceux qui vivent avec vous
des obligations assez stricte c'est à
dire des obligations de ne pas sortir
car si vous vous confiné parce que vous
êtes porteur du virus chez vous mais que
vous contaminer ceux qui vivent avec
vous et que eux peuvent sortir alors le
résultat est très mauvaise
donc soit vous déciderez et vous pourrez
vous confiné chez vous avec l'ensemble
des membres du foyer soit vous déciderez
vous devrez vous confiné dans un lieu
qui n'est pas votre domicile qui pourra
être un hôtel mis à votre disposition
qui seront évidemment sollicités pour
permettre d'accueillir un certain nombre
de patients avec un suivi médical avec
des règles de fonctionnement et dans ce
cas là vous passerez une durée
déterminée de temps dans cet hôtel
dans ce lieu pour éviter de contaminer
d'autres personnes et ensuite à la fin
après l'examen médical vous pourrez
évidemment reprendre une vie normale
testé puis ensuite isolés c'est ça que
ça veut dire et c'est très lourd
ce sont des décisions qui sont lourdes à
prendre qui sont lourdes à vivre et qui
impacte évidemment la vie normale
quotidienne de nos concitoyens mais
compte tenu de ce que nous avons dit
auparavant c'est pour ça que nous
prenons le temps de l'expliquer de
l'absence de vaccin que l'absence de
traitement du risque associé à une
grande circulation du virus
nous considérons que cette méthode est
la seule que nous soyons en mesure de
mettre en oeuvre de façon à garantir la
limitation dans la circulation du virus
c'est autour de cette architecture que
le système fonctionnera avec évidemment
comme l'a très bien dit le ministre des
solidarités de la santé
l'identification et le suivi des cas
contactez dès lors que vous aurez été
testé positif
voilà les principes ils doivent être
travaillés dans leur application ils le
sont en ce moment à la fois par l'équipe
qui pilote l'organisation du
déconfinement sous l'autorité de jean
castex qui nous avons confié cette
mission mais qui le fait évidemment en
travaillant et en sang en consultant et
en écoutant tous ceux qui sont
directement intéressés par la mise en
oeuvre de ces mesures
les collectivités territoriales les
organisations syndicales et patronales
l'ensemble des acteurs économiques
politiques sociaux de ce pays
qui évidemment doivent nous assister
nous aider être sur la même ligne dans
la façon de mettre en oeuvre ces règles
sans quoi elle ne serait pas efficace et
vivre avec le virus
donc ce sont des gestes barrières c'est
la distanciation social dans l'ensemble
des activités qui sont appelés à
reprendre à compter du 11 mai et c'est
évidemment au cas par cas
parfois délicat à organiser dans les
transports nous sommes aujourd'hui
l'équivalent d'environ 10% du plan de
transport c'est-à-dire que les
transports ont été réduits à dix pour
cent de ceux qu'ils sont normalement les
transports publics notamment dès lors
que nous allons procéder progressivement
déconfinement à nos concitoyens vont
devoir se déplacer monter dans des bus
monter dans des trains utilisez des
métros nous des tramways est donc se
retrouver dans des configurations où la
densité qui relativement limité
aujourd'hui parce que nous sommes en
période de confinement va être
évidemment beaucoup plus grande il faut
donc là encore que nous étudions les
gestes barrières et la distanciation qui
est susceptible d'être mise en oeuvre
les transports sont un des cas où le
port du masque pourra être obligatoire à
compter du 11 mai nous sommes en train
d'étudier les conditions dans lesquelles
cela peut être mises en oeuvre mais il
est probable que s'agissant des
transports publics
s'agissant de ces lieux où la densité
mécaniquement assez forte
il soit obligatoire pour les utiliser de
porter un masque grand public dans les
entreprises les gestes barrières et la
distanciation sociale doivent passer
d'abord lorsque c'est possible par le
maintien du télétravail
beaucoup de nos concitoyens se sont mis
bardon pour l'expression au télétravail
beaucoup peuvent le faire beaucoup ont
pu profiter de cette possibilité
il va falloir faire en sorte que ce
télétravail se poursuivent dans toute la
mesure du possible
et puis quand il n'est pas possible et
évidemment beaucoup d'activité ou des
pâtes du tout possible de faire du
télétravail
alors il va falloir que les règles dans
anisation de l'entreprise respecte ces
mesures barrières et cette distanciation
social c'est possible il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises qui fonctionne aujourd'hui
dans de bonnes conditions
il faut pour cela que les méthodes de
travail et été discutée probablement
accepté par les salariés
il faut sans doute regarder dans quel
cas là encore le port du masque peut
être utile recommandée voire le cas
échéant obligatoires il y à des guides
qui sont réalisés qui ont commencé à
être réalisé qu'ils vont continuer à
être réalisés réalisé par les branches
réalisé avec le ministre du travail pour
faire en sorte que les bonnes consignes
soient soit soit donnée est respecté
dans la vie de l'entreprise
s'agissant des commerces nous allons
progressivement ré ouvrir les commerces
que nous avons fermé alors pas les cafés
les restaurants dans un premier temps ce
qui est pour tous ceux qui vivent de
cette activité à la fois un crève coeur
et une angoisse considérable parce que
cette nature d'activité ne permet pas de
l'imiter dans un premier temps la
circulation du virus mais d'autres
commerces qui aujourd'hui sont fermés
vont pouvoir ré ouvrir ils le pourront
l'être qu'en respectant ses gestes
barrières cette distanciation social
quel que soit le commerce en question
les files d'attentes devront être
organisées de telle manière que les
distances minimales de plus d'un mètre
soit respectée entre les clients des
mesures comme par exemple la mise à
disposition de gel hydroalcoolique à
l'entrée du magasin ou juste avant la
caisse devront être mises en oeuvre pour
là encore multiplier ces gestes
barrières et diminuer au maximum la
circulation du virus et sa vitesse
enfin les écoles la question des écoles
est une question à la fois sensible qui
interroge beaucoup de nos concitoyens
les professeurs les parents d'élèves
beaucoup de nos concitoyens qui se
demandent comment est ce que les écoles
vont pouvoir ouvrir le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a passé toute la
semaine à discuter avec les
organisations syndicales qui
représentent les professeurs celle qui
représente les chefs d'établissements
les fédérations de parents d'élèves les
associations d'élus qui évidemment des
responsabilités éminentes en matière
d'éducation les maires pour les écoles
de maternelle et primaire
les département pour les collèges les
régions pour les lycées et l'objectif
c'est de trouver la bonne méthode
à l'évidence je veux le dire cette bonne
méthode sera progressive
les écoles n'ouvriront pas partout le 11
mai et ne fonctionnera pas un partout le
11 mai dans les conditions dans
lesquelles elle fonctionnait le 11
février ou le 11 janvier où avant les
les mesures de confinement mais nous
devons commencer à ouvrir les écoles
pour une raison très simple qui tient à
l'impératif de continuité de la vie de
la nation que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui beaucoup de professeurs font
un travail remarquable pour accompagner
les élèves alors même que nous sommes en
période de confinement il travaille de
chez eux utilisent les nouvelles
technologies
il donne du travail parfois ils font des
cours qui sont diffusés par internet
il donne des consignes il corrige bref
ils font en sorte que le lien entre
l'élève et le professeur qui évidemment
d'une nature très différente en période
de confinement et parfois d'une nature
un peu insatisfaisante soit maintenu que
le travail d'acquisition de réflexion
j'allais dire d'élévation même des
élèves puissent se poursuivre mais un
certain nombre d'élèves n'ont pas accès
à ces instruments un certain nombre
d'élèves soit pour des raisons liée à
l'inégalité territoriale
l'inégalité sociale
on se retrouve dans une situation où le
lien avec l'école est rompu et ce n'est
pas un petit nombre d'élèves
c'est une proportion de l'ordre de 5 à
10% nous disent les professeurs les
professeurs eux-mêmes mais qui
évidemment peut être beaucoup plus
importante dans certains territoires ou
dans certains quartiers qui se trouvent
privés de tout contact avec l'école
cette situation est une situation qui
présente pour la nation un grave danger
et nous devons donc faire en sorte que
l'ensemble des enfants
bien entendu mais singulièrement ceux
qui voient le lien avec l'école se
distendre le plus puissent reprendre le
chemin de l'école comme l'a indiqué le
président de la république il faut
qu'ils puissent le faire dans des
conditions de sécurité sanitaire
respectez bien entendu les enfants
c'est ce que nous disent les
scientifiques ne craignent ne semble je
vais utiliser des termes prudents ne
semble rien craindre pour eux mêmes car
l'immense majorité la quasi exclusivité
des enfants sont atteints par des formes
bénignes voix totalement asymptomatiques
de la maladie mais ils peuvent
transmettre le virus
il faut donc garantir les gestes
barrière dans l'école et c'est
évidemment difficile il faut évidemment
éviter que le circulent ne le pardon que
le virus ne puisse remettre à circuler à
cause du rassemblement des enfants
il faudra donc mettre en place des
mesures progressives j'ai demandé au
ministre de l'éducation nationale nous
avons demandé ensemble à ce que des
scénarii des hypothèses soit travailler
avec nos partenaires pour voir lesquels
seraient les plus susceptibles de nous
permettre de ré ouvrir progressivement
les écoles des scénarios différencier
par exemple selon les territoires
dans un certain nombre de territoires en
france dans certains départements il n'y
a eu quasiment aucun cas et on peut
évidemment considérer qu'après deux mois
de confinement
cette situation sera préservée et que
donc les territoires seront presque
exemple de virus ou en tout cas avec une
présence négligeable on peut imaginer
que dans ces territoires
l'ouverture se fasse plus rapidement
façon plus large que dans d'autres
territoires où la situation est plus
compliquée parce que le virus a plus
circuler où circulent encore un peu plus
je ne dis pas que c'est ce qu'il faut
faire
je dis que nous devons nous poser la
question est étudiée localement la façon
dont il est possible de réouvrir les
écoles de la même façon nous pouvons
évidemment imaginer des hypothèses où ce
serait des moitiés de classe qui
rentrerait à partir du 11 mai et qui une
semaine sur deux pourrait avoir le lien
physique et intellectuel avec le
professeur pour ensuite alterné avec
l'autre moitié de la classe qu'on peut
imaginer l'utilisation des locaux de
façon différente en utilisant des
espaces plus larges que de simples
classe pour faire court on peut imaginer
beaucoup de choses et nous devons
travailler sur toutes les hypothèses
nous devons travailler sur toutes ces
hypothèses avec les maires qu'un rôle
éminent nous devons travailler sur ces
hypothèses avec les professeurs qui
savent comment
ils peuvent faire cours comment ils
souhaitent faire court nous devons
travailler ces hypothèses avec
l'ensemble des partenaires
c'est un fait un énorme travail de
préparation il a commencé je ne veux pas
faire état de décision à ce stade car
elles sont en train d'être travaillés
mais je souhaitais évoquer ses
hypothèses pour que chacun en conscience
en bonne intelligence puisse envisager
la suite
et le cas échéant prendre part au débat
dernier mot de cette présentation sur la
façon dont nous réfléchissons aux
déconfinement la question des publics
les plus vulnérables face au virus nous
savons c'est sûr que pèsent les risques
les plus fondamentaux il faut donc que
dans le déconfinement leur situation
soit prise en compte de façon spécifique
je passe la parole au ministre de la
santé
très rapidement monsieur le premier
ministre nous allons faire appel à la
responsabilisation individuelle de
chacun on le sait il y à des personnes
qui sont plus fragiles que d'autres face
au virus et qui font beaucoup plus de
complications que d'autres mais parfois
qui décèdent davantage que les autres
fallait-il décidé après le 11 mai nke
sert une catégorie de la population en
fonction de l'âge en fonction de
fragilité il ya des maladies chroniques
resterait confiné de manière obligatoire
quand une autre partie seraient elles
libres de circuler avec toutes les
réserves et l'application des gestes
barrières non on peut avoir
soixante dix ans 75 ans être en pleine
forme ne pas avoir de fragilité
particulière et ne pas comprendre
pourquoi est-ce qu'on se verrait intimé
l'ordre de rester chez soi en revanche
véritablement nous allons multiplier les
messages de prévention en direction des
publics fragiles des personnes encore
une fois dans les fragilités peuvent
impliquer des maladies plus graves plus
fréquentes et donc faire appel à la
responsabilisation individuelle et dans
le même temps nous maintiendrons toutes
les mesures que j'ai eu l'occasion de
préciser tout à l'heure toutes les
mesures qui visent à favoriser le
maintien à domicile des personnes
isolées
confiné donc attention très particulière
pour les personnes les plus fragiles et
les personnes âgées messages de
prévention renouveler tout sera mis en
place par la puissance publique pour
permettre aux personnes concernées de
rester chez elles mais pas d'obligation
à rester quand une autre catégorie de
population pourrait elle sortir de chez
elles au fond l'idée importante parmi
les idées importantes à retenir de ce
travail sur le déconfinement et sur la
façon dont il va se réaliser c'est que
nous allons tous être acteur de ce
déconfinement il nous reviendra à nous
tous de la même façon que nous avons
souhaité être responsable au moment du
confinement d'être responsable au moment
du des confirmands de faire en sorte que
les gestes barrières les mesures
particulières mises en oeuvre pour
limiter la circulation du virus soit
respectée pour préparer le plan de
déconfinement que je présenterai à la
fin du mois d'avril comme le président
de la république me l'a demandé
une équipe d'experts est piloté par jean
castex
c'est important de pouvoir faire la
coordination de la doctrine de pouvoir
faire la masse est la somme de toutes
les questions qui se posent vous pouvoir
vérifier que les décisions qui seront
prises par l'état dans tel ou tel
domaine sont bien cohérente et
compatible avec un certain nombre de
problèmes qui se posent localement nous
allons donc évidemment mobilisé
l'ensemble de l'administration c'est la
moindre des choses mais aussi mobiliser
les collectivités territoriales les
partenaires sociaux qui ont deux aussi
un rôle très important à jouer
au coeur du dispositif qui doit être
mise en oeuvre
il y aura le couple maire préfet parce
que même si le déconfinement doit
respecter des principes généraux même si
des éléments de doctrine cohérente
doivent prévaloir sur l'ensemble du
territoire national
c'est localement que les solutions
seront trouvées c localement qu'on sera
capable de déterminer les endroits dans
lesquels il pourra être procédé au test
et ça c'est pas le gouvernement qui va
le décider
ce sera le travail entre les maires et
les préfets en fonction des contraintes
locales des disponibilités local des
endroits où les tests peuvent être
effectués où ils peuvent être analysées
ce ne sont pas ça ne peut pas être le
gouvernement qui tout seul va dire
l'isolément pour avoir lieu à tel
endroit ou à telle autre
là encore c'est un travail intense entre
les maires et les préfets et les maires
et les sous-préfets qui va permettre de
déterminer le dispositif précis de
déconfinement nous aurons sur les
conditions de ce déconfinement un débat
parlementaire au début du mois de mai il
est indispensable car il ya beaucoup de
choses qui vont se jouer dans ceux des
confinement est comme gelée toujours
indiquée il est nécessaire que le
parlement puisse continuer à exercer son
rôle de contrôle de l'activité du
gouvernement
ces questions ces questions exigeante
ces questions sur l'ensemble des sujets
que le parlement croit nécessaire
d'aborder nous aurons ce débat début
mais de façon à rendre public l'ensemble
des questions qui se posent et les
débats politiques qui s'en suivent
et puis il y aura une mise en oeuvre
progressive à partir du 11 mai je le dis
elle ne sera elle ne peut pas être autre
chose que progressive à partir du 11 mai
nous entrons dans une deuxième phase
nous allons reconquérir une partie de
notre liberté
sans remettre en cause notre santé mais
en devant respecter des règles qui
seront contraignantes c'est vrai moins
contraignante que le confinement mais
contraignante de façon à faire en sorte
que nous puissions recommencer à vivre
le plus normalement possible
voilà ce que nous voulions vous dire
avec
le ministre des solidarités de la santé
dans cette présentation un peu longue
mais il ya des questions nous y
répondons aussi longtemps que vous
souhaiterez nous en poser
merci bonjour monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le ministre
camille colin donc pour tf1 et lci je
vais effectivement me faire le relais
aujourd'hui de toutes les questions de
mes confrères des autres rédactions
avant cela j'ai moi même une question et
voilà donc pour la conférence de presse
le point sur la situation du coronavirus
ce soir par edouard philippe et le
ministre de la santé
olivier véran bonsoir bienvenue sur rt
france ce nouveau point presse donc du
directeur général de la santé d'edouard
philippe ainsi que le ministre de la
santé après l'annonce d'un déconfinement
le 11 mai par emmanuel macron c'était
lundi dernier les français attendaient
des précisions sur les modalités de la
sortie progressive de déconfinement
alors que les français entament leur
deuxième mois chez eux une feuille de
route est toujours en préparation a dit
edouard philippe
elle sera dévoilée dans les quinze jours
prochains pas de réponse concrète donc
ce soir mais beaucoup d'hypothèses
edouard philippe qui a a néanmoins
averti les français il va falloir
adopter de nouvelles habitudes le
quotidien sera différente
écoutez le je sais que beaucoup de ceux
qui nous regardent aimerait que j'entre
dans le détail de ce qui va se passer
le 11 mai et dans les jours les semaines
et les mois qui suivront je ne répondrai
pas à toutes ces questions aujourd'hui
je le ferai bientôt dans les quinze
jours qui viennent lorsque je
présenterai le plan que le président de
la république m'a demandé de préparer
il est en train d'être travaillé dans
tous ses détails et nous serons au
rendez vous et voilà donc pour la
déclaration d' edouard philippe
on en parle tout avec ian brossât
porte-parole du parti communiste
français
bonsoir ian brossât merci beaucoup avec
nous sur rt france alors ça a duré très
longtemps deux heures d'exposé deux
heures parfois un peu complexe
d'ailleurs sur ce que l'on sait ce que
l'on ne sait pas l'état des stocks
l'état de la menace les défis à relever
qu'en avez vous retenu de ces deux
heures d'exposé de d'edouard philippe et
et son ministre de la santé
j'ai trouvé que c'était une conférence
de presse enfin une allocution en
réalité qui était à la fois très longue
et finalement assez incomplète parce que
les français se posent aujourd'hui
beaucoup de questions beaucoup de
questions sur l'état de leur système de
santé beaucoup de questions sur ce à
quoi le déconfinement ressemblera et sur
ces deux questions là on n'a pas
véritablement de réponse et le sentiment
qu'on a c'est que en matière de
déconfinement il y a pour l'instant une
date qui a été fixée par le président de
la république mais il n'y a pas de plan
il n'y a pas de plan de déconfinement et
le premier ministre reconnaît d'ailleurs
lui même qu'il n'a pas de réponse à
cette question là or c'est précisément
la question principale que les français
se posent aujourd'hui
oui d'autant qu'il l'a avoué il n'y a
toujours pas suffisamment de matériel de
protection pour le personnel soignant
est ce que c'est parce que justement on
ne sait pas encore comment est ce qu'on
va pouvoir protéger au niveau des
masques les français notamment que ceux
des confinement a en tout cas ce plan se
fait attendre selon vous mais bien
évidemment c'est parce que nous n'avons
pas de masque en nombre suffisant parce
que nous n'avons pas de test en nombre
suffisant qu'on ne peut pas aujourd'hui
préciser les conditions du déconfinement
et qui par ailleurs quand le premier
ministre nous dit avec une forme d'auto
satisfaction qu'il est très heureux que
la france produisent non plus 4 millions
de masques par semaine mais 8 millions
de masques par semaine grâce aux grands
efforts réalisés par le gouvernement
il ya comme un décalage c'est peut-être
qu'au maroc on produit 5 millions de
masques par jour qu'en allemagne on a un
objectif de production de 50 millions de
masques par semaine et donc la france
est très très très loin de tout ça parce
que depuis des années nous avons
affaibli nos capacités productives nous
n'avons plus vérité
ble ment d'état qui se mobilisent pour
défendre son industrie et c'est ce que
nous payons aujourd'hui et je pense
qu'on aurait besoin que le gouvernement
fasse dans ce domaine une vraie auto
critique et qu'on se donne les moyens de
reconstruire nos capacités productives
en france oui c'est ce qu'a évoqué
d'ailleurs oublié verront faire revenir
justement toutes ces entreprises
primordial les laboratoires toutes les
entreprises qui qui participent à la
sécurité sanitaire des français les
faire revenir en france à apprendre du
temps ça aussi ce que vous pensez ça va
prendre du temps mais surtout il
faudrait qu'on ait l'assurance que le
gouvernement est prêt à le faire aux
recettes en contradiction totale avec la
politique qui a été menée dans notre
pays depuis des années maintenant et
singulièrement depuis qu emmanuel macron
et président de la république nous
payons une logique qui a consisté à
laisser notre industrie se délocaliser
et à perdre une forme de notre de notre
souveraineté et donc il y a besoin d'une
vraie rupture
en tout cas pour ce qui nous concerne au
parti communiste nous l'appelons de nos
voeux et je ne pense pas véritablement
qu'on puisse compter sur ce gouvernement
là pour engager cette rupture
ou alors ce serait un vrai changement
par rapport à ce qu'on a vu depuis deux
ans maintenant il ya une annonce
concrète ce soit c'est dès demain le
l'autorisation des visites dans les
ehpad
c'est essentiel évidemment on imagine
pour la psychologie l'équilibré
psychologique des personnes qui
souffrent actuellement dans ces
établissements
sa nouvelle oui c'est une bonne chose
parce qu'on en était arrivé à une
situation totalement inhumaines ou des
personnes âgées se retrouver seul en
ehpad sans que leurs familles et la
possibilité d'aller leur rendre visite
cela dit il y à des questions qui
restent entières premier ministre a dit
on a fait 50 mille tests dans les ehpad
on a besoin d'en faire bien davantage
parce qu'on sait que les soignants dans
les ehpad les personnels dans les ehpad
particulièrement explorer exposés aux
échos ville et donc on a beau
d'une montée en puissance des tests et
c'est aussi ce qui ce qui permettra que
la situation s'améliore dans les ehpad
parce que franchement s'il ya bien
quelque chose qui devrait faire honte à
notre pays aujourd'hui c'est la
situation de nos de nos maisons de
retraite
ian brossât vous êtes adjoint à la
mairie de paris anne hidalgo a annoncé
qu'il y aura des masses pour les
parisiens d'ici à la fin du mois d'avril
vous confirmez oui il y aura cinq cent
mille masques qui seront disponibles à
la fin du mois d'avril en priorité pour
les personnes les plus fragiles pour les
personnes âgées et dc le déconfinement
donc d'ici la mi mai il y aura un masque
pour chaque parisien comme la maire de
paris s'y était engagé on est d'ailleurs
dans une situation au delà de paris où
les collectivités locales font beaucoup
et où les collectivités locales d'une
certaine manière se substitue à l'état
c'est parce que l'état n'est pas capable
de le faire que les collectivités
locales sont amenés à mettre en place
des politiques qui visent à protéger
leurs populations
c'est ce que nous faisons à paris mais
c'est ce que d'autres maires d'autres
couleurs politiques d'ailleurs font sur
leur territoire
edouard philippe a dit qu'il fallait
assurer la continuité de la nation c'est
la priorité de ceux des confinement à
travers évidemment la reprise du travail
et la réouverture des écoles de sachs
qui l'a détaillé pour préserver
notamment pour essayer de réfléchir à
des mesures pour préserver la sécurité
des français
mais en tout cas rétablir aussi la
capacité d'accueil dans les hôpitaux
voilà à peu près la stratégie qui va
être mise en oeuvre le travail la remise
au travail à l'école à partir du rose
mais vous y croyez mais à quel prix la
reprise du travail
bien sûr simplement la reprise du
travail dans des conditions qui évite
aux salariés de courir des risques
sanitaires et de la même manière
d'ailleurs à l'école le premier ministre
nous dit il y aura un certain nombre
d'élèves c'est pas bien lesquels
d'ailleurs qui reprendront le chemin de
l'école à partir du 11 mai mais il n'y a
aujourd'hui aucune espèce de précision
sur les conditions dans lesquelles
l'école pourra reprendre
donc il y a encore après cette
conférence de presse beaucoup de
questions bien sûr que la vie doit
reprendre après le 11 mai mais le rôle
de l'état le rôle de n'importe quel état
c'est de faire en sorte qu'on puisse
reprendre la vie si ce n'est normal du
moins une vie qui ressemble un peu plus
à la vie de tous les jours mais dans des
conditions sanitaires qui soit celle
d'un grand pays comme la france c'est je
crois le défi auquel nous sommes
confrontés aujourd'hui et les questions
auxquelles il faudra répondre dans les
jours qui viennent parce que pour
l'instant sur ces questions là on n'a
pas véritablement de réponse aucune
aucune réponse on a entendu le chef du
gouvernement dira on imagine des classes
réduites de moitié on imagine des élèves
qui viendraient une semaine sur deux
voilà donc toutes les hypothèses sont
sur la table et on ne sait toujours pas
qui seraient concernés les élèves
on le sait qu'ils ont des difficultés
scolaires dans certaines zones peut-être
rentrer avant d'autres vous vous pensez
que c'est la bonne méthode ce serait en
tout cas la bonne méthode
moi je pense que l'école et c'est son
principe même
elle doit s'adresser à l'ensemble des
élèves quel que soit le lieu dans lequel
ils vivent quelles que soient les
origines sociales de leurs parents est
ce qui fait la richesse de l'école c'est
précisément le brassage social
et c'est précisément ce pour l'instant
vers quoi on se dirige pas puisqu'on
nous dit que ce sont uniquement les
enfants les plus fragiles ou ceux des
milieux les plus modestes qui
reprendront le chemin de l'école demain
moi je pense surtout qu'on aurait besoin
que le gouvernement mette en place les
mesures nécessaires les masques les
tests qui permettent que tout le monde
puisse revenir à l'école simplement
comme il n'ya pas de masse
pas de test en nombre suffisant ça ne
sera pas possible le 11 mai prochain
donc tous a conduit le gouvernement à
une forme d'improvisation de flou tout
ça reste très nébuleux et c'est ce qui
pose je crois problèmes aux trois pistes
évoquées par edouard philippe maintenir
le télétravail
on est sur une autre forme de vie là oui
enfin quand on parle du télétravail on
parle quand même d'une classe sociale
qui n'est pas l'ensemble des classes
sociales ce qui télétravaillent ce son
et en mieux pour eux d'ailleurs si ça
alors
ça leur convient ce sont pour
l'essentiel les cadres mais aujourd'hui
il y a malheureusement des salariés qui
continuent à travailler eux dans des
conditions qui parfois ne sont pas
particulièrement sûr je pense au monde
du travail aux ouvriers aux employés qui
parfois continuer à bosser à l'usiné
pour ce qui concerne les ouvriers dans
des conditions très difficiles
quand on voit aussi ce qui s'est passé
avec amazon et le fait que la justice
ait été contrainte d'intervenir
on voit qu'on a des salariés qui sont
aujourd'hui très très exposé et donc ce
que je dis c'est qu'il faut faire
attention à une espèce de deux poids
deux mesures où on aurait des catégories
supérieures qui elle serait protégé et
des catégories plus modestes ouvriers
employés qui elles seraient exposées aux
risques sans que leur santé ne soient
protégés dernière question ian brossât
le 28 avril prochain à l'assemblée
nationale il y aura un débat pour savoir
si on met en place ces fameuses
applications pour traquer les personnes
qui seraient susceptibles d'être
contaminés parcours d'un virus qu'en
pensez vous moi je n'y suis pas
favorable et je pense qu'on ne doit pas
mettre le doigt dans un engrenage comme
celui là qui serait une atteinte à nos
libertés sans savoir d'ailleurs de
quelle manière serait ensuite utilisé
ces données
donc bien sûr nous devons veiller à
notre santé bien sûr nous devons mettre
en place tous les moyens de la protéger
mais nous ne devons pas profiter de ce
moment d'une certaine manière pour
remettre en cause un certain nombre de
libertés de libertés fondamentales merci
beaucoup ian brossât a répondu à nos
questions sur arte france et on va
prendre tout de suite la direction de
matignon pour rejoindre notre reporter
sur place nadège abderrazak bonsoir
nadège vous avez suivi cette longue
conférence de presse d'edouard philippe
et d'être ministre de là sans écho
faut-il en retenir pour traitement
il faudra vivre avec le virus la
population n'est pas immunisée pas de
vaccin avant 2021 et même de traitement
éducation connu ce même si la recherche
se poursuit
le premier ministre s'est montré
réaliste aujourd'hui six jours après la
dernière allocution d' emmanuel macron
accompagné du ministre de la santé il a
procédé à un état des lieux sur la
gestion du coronavirus la prévention
sera déterminante dit-il dans la
politique de déconfinement le premier
ministre a indiqué qu'il faudra à
continuer à vivre avec le respect des
gestes-barrières qu'il faudra à tester
tous ceux à qui présentent des symptômes
est en contact avéré avec des personnes
malades appelé à isoler également et
porteurs de virus le ministre de la
santé a appelé également est bien
attestée le maximum de personnes âgées
dans les bras dans l'est
merci
c'est précision elle nadège alter hasard
en direct de l'hôtel matignon à paris et
pour continuer à débriefer cette
conférence de presse du chef du
gouvernement et son ministre de la santé
nous ça nous allait que georges
kuzmanovic présidents de républiques
souveraines
bonsoir georges kuzmanovic merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france à guingamp
qu'avez vous retenu vous spécifiquement
de de cette conférence de presse
d'edouard philippe et de son ministre de
la santé qui a duré je le rappelle un
peu moins de deux heures une très longue
conférence de presse qui a mêlé de
nombreux sujets l'idée principale de
cette conférence de presse était de
parler du plan de déconfinement alors
malheureusement on apprend n'existe pas
et qu' il ne sera prêt que dans quinze
jours ça veut dire que si la date du 11
mai est maintenue il ne restera plus aux
français qu'une semaine entre
l'explication du plan et là le début du
déconfinement pour comprendre à ce plan
et le mettre en oeuvre
à l'heure actuelle et pour ce qu'on a
dit mais ce flip le premier ministre le
déconfinement semble très peu préparés
au niveau du gouvernement
et si l'on s'en réfère aux exemples
existants c'est à dire ceux de taiwan de
la corée du sud ou du vietnam qui
montrait un certain succès il va nous en
sommes loin
cela implique d'avoir énormément pas
suffisamment de masques pour l'ensemble
de la population ce n'est pas le cas
selon les chiffres mêmes du premier
ministre nous en produisons 8 millions
par semaine il a annoncé des chiffres de
45 millions de masques nécessaire de
manière hebdomadaire hors des collectifs
de médecins eux disent qu'il en faudrait
100 5 millions peut-être fait une mini
minimisation la des besoins en masques
par le parrain gouvernement qui s'est
largement emmêlé les pinceaux dans
l'approvisionnement en masque de la
france
il faudra des gants il faudra du gel
hydroalcoolique est-ce qu'il faudra un
système de traçage vous en avez parlé
tout à l'heure mais où rappelle encore
et le système de traçage ce n'est pas
juste une application ces vingt mille
personnes spécifiquement dédié à
lenquête et au suivi des de ceux qui
sont contaminés en france serait de 30
mille personnes je vois très mal comment
le gouvernement pour un mort et trente
mille personnes ou suivi des contaminés
en trois semaines assez implique des
nettoyages massif dans les rues dans les
transports en commun pareillement ceci
n'a pas été annoncée et puis cela repose
également sur un nombre de lignes
nous sommes malgré tout toujours à la
limite du débordement nous n'avons que
cinq mille lits en france contre 27 27
millions allemagne en france et trois
lits pour 1000 habitants et les normes
de sécurité que l'on voit en asie son de
dj part pour 1000 habitants du coin est
très loin et se tournent déconfinement
s'annonce très très mal pour l'instant
évidemment il ya des manques qu'on va il
va falloir faire avec ce qu'on a en
france
être capable de faire face à une
nouvelle vague c'est surtout ça l'enjeu
du déconfinement vous l'avez dit 5000
lits en réanimation en temps normal on a
doublé ses capacités il faut être en
mesure de pouvoir accueillir de nouveaux
malades si une nouvelle épidémie se
déclencher à presse déconfinement c'est
surtout ça l'enjeu c'est exactement ça
l'enjeu et moi personnellement
république souveraine ce qui nous
inquiète tout particulièrement c'est la
réouverture des écoles
le lendemain de l'allocution du
président nombre de syndicats
d'enseignants nombre de parents d'élèves
est encore plus spécifiquement nombre
d'organisations médicales ont dit que
c'était absurde et si je me réfère à
l'étude qui a été fait par un
laboratoire de mathématiques attaché à
l'inserm dont l'étude est sorti le 12
avril un déconfinement augmente bien
évidemment les risques de saturation des
lits en hôpitaux dans leur modélisation
ça va de 40 fois à deux fois
en fonction de l'efficacité du programme
mais dans tous les cas c'est sans la
reprise des écoles et moi j'en avais
comprendre très concrètement j'ai une
des trois filles l'une d'entre elles à 5
ans elle est en classe de maternelle
il y à 120 140 élèves dans son école
donc ça veut dire à 16h30 à 18h quelque
70 80 parents qui mettent comme on fait
sortir les enfants dans quel ordre
avec une distance sociale d'un mètre
cinquante rentrent chaque parent vous
imaginez le chaos
en fait ça me semble très très peu
sérieux d'autant plus qu'on voit mal
comment des gestes barrières ou à être
appliquées par des enfants surtout en
bas âge qu'il n'ya pas les masques et
que même si effectivement les enfants
ensemble asymptomatiques
ils sont vecteurs de la maladie c'est
prendre un risque
colossal pour l'ensemble de la nation
pour un gain économique qui semble très
faible au moment où on se parle à la
priorité à priori c'est le décrochage
scolaire qui est provoqué par par ce
confinement des élèves qui ne sont plus
identifiés par leurs professeurs donc
pas forcément les petits plus tôt
d'ailleurs les plus grands oui je devais
amener le décrochage scolaire en france
est un problème est récurrent est ancien
c'est le manque de financement le manque
de salaires des enseignants le manque de
moyens pour pour l'école les classes
surchargées
il y à déjà auparavant un problème de
décrochement là bien évidemment qu'il y
à un risque de ce côté là mais on peut
pas faire reprendre l'école pour un mois
au titre que cela règlerait le problème
des décrochements ce décrochement
scolaire et mettre à risque la santé de
l'ensemble du pays c'est ce n'est pas
pour rien qu'un certain nombre de
professionnels de santé disent que cette
absurde on va écouter injustement ce
qu'il en est pour les ehpad georges
kuzmanovic une annonce a été faite
écouter le premier ministre
tandis que le confinement est amenée à
durer encore pour plusieurs semaines
il nous a semblé utile de consulter à
nouveau les sociétés savantes les
représentants des organismes de ces
établissements pour personnes âgées et
nous avons élaboré ensemble des
recommandations nouvelles qui
permettront à partir de demain
d'organiser dans les territoires sous la
responsabilité des directions
d'établissement un droit de visite pour
les familles à direction direction de
leurs aînés fragile admis en ehpad ce
sera à la demande du résident ce sera
dans des conditions extrêmement vous
l'imaginez limitez pas plus de deux
personnes de la famille à tout le monde
en même temps ce sera sous la
responsabilité des directions encore une
fois d'établissement qui devront dire à
la famille lorsque ce sera possible et
dans quelles conditions sachant que la
sécurité sanitaire reste au coeur de
notre projet et qu'il y aura donc
l'impossibilité maintenu d'aller toucher
la personne d'être en contact physique
par contre il y aura un contact visuel
voilà donc un droit de visite dans les
ehpad n'ont pas annoncé par le premier
ministre mais par le ministre de la
santé
c'est là la seule la seule annonce
finalement concrètes qu'on a entendu
aujourd'hui
oui effectivement c'est la seule annonce
concrète mais là encore c'est très haut
dans cette cette intervention de du
ministre de la santé sur le contact
visuel ce qu'il faut là encore c'est des
masques et des tests comme nous le
répétons la plus souveraine depuis
depuis maintenant plus de six semaines
on pourrait parfaitement imaginer que il
y ait des visites qui sont nécessaires
pour bien de nos aînés qui sont
malheureuses tout seuls dans leur ehpad
avec leur maladie est en fin de vie et
on peut si nous avions des tests je
n'avais avions des capacités
industrielles permettant à 7 est vous
pouvez bien imaginer des tests juste
avant l'entrée en ehpad si le test est
négatif alors les personnes qui
visiterait leur ancien pour le visiter
en toute tranquillité sans craindre de
leur transmettre la maladie
bon mais le problème c'est que nous
n'avons encore pas ces tests ça avance
très très lentement et nous n'avons pas
les masques et je vois très mal comment
est ce que nous pourrions avoir
encore une fois au regard des chiffres
annoncés par le premier ministre
lui-même qui sont souvent plus positive
que la réalité la capacité de fournir 60
8 millions de compatriotes en masque
quotidiennement puisque je vous rappelle
en plus il faut plusieurs masques par
jour
je voudrais là-dessus également alors
faire une remarque ça m'a beaucoup
intéressé d'entendre dans les propos de
monsieur véran et du premier ministre le
fait que nous avons un système de
protection sociale qui est un
amortisseur et que l'on nous envie dans
de nombreux pays
bien évidemment et heureusement qu'on
l'a et comme l'a dit premier ministre je
n'avais pas du tout être aux états unis
actuellement où il y a déjà 22 millions
de chômeurs sans aucune sécurité sans
aucune sécurité sociale or ce
gouvernement et les gouvernements
précédents ont tout fait pour détruire
justement ce modèle social et la réforme
de retraites
on était le dernier volet tout cela
montre bien que heureusement qu'on a
encore des restes de ce qui nous
venaient du conseil national de la
résistance
donc une un système qui permette d'avoir
une république sociale qui protège les
plus faibles qui protège l'ensemble de
la société coque nous retrouvons dans
une crise de cette ampleur
on a vu d'ailleurs on y reviendra dans
nos prochaines éditions un implant des
deux massifs aussi également au niveau
économique on en reparlera merci
beaucoup georges kuzmanovic d'avoir
répondu à nos questions c'est la fin de
cette édition spéciale consacrée au
point-presse d'edouard philippe et de
son ministre de la santé
restez avec nous l'info revient dans en
15 minutes exactement
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
bienvenue sur rt france dans le débrief
du doc dans cette émission décryptage et
analyse du documentaire consacré à la
rude vie dans cette ville du mexique
tristement célèbre pour le gang qu'elle
abrite le cartel de sinaloa un gant
considéré comme le plus puissant au
monde et